FIRST. MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET TO ORDER. A
JUST A COUPLE HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
BUT TODAY WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
BRIEF PRESENTATION. FROM
DEPARTMENT FINANCES WAS OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST REGARDING
THE GUARD THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL ABOUT WE'RE NOT
TAKING A VOTE BY THE PALACE ON
THE AGENDA ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY. THEN WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM. AS
WELL n
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS.
877-692-8957 THEN THE- ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- OH TWO AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY ISSUES PLEASE CALL
OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT. 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL BE THERE TO
ASSIST YOU. THE GOVERNOR
RELEASED THE JANUARY BUDGET AND
THIS IS ON THE HEELS OF OUR-
BUDGET FROM. LAST YEAR APPROVED
LAST JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR. THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND AS
YOU KNOW WHEN THAT BUDGET AS
WELL AS IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
WE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH OUR
COBIT. ADAMEK HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS REMAIN TOP ISSUES.
NOT JUST IN OUR URBAN AREAS BUT
IN ALMOST EVERY PART OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS OUR-
HOUSING CRISIS HAS REALLY
SPREAD. THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE AND WERE SEEN- IMPACTS OF
IT THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AS WELL- EDUCATION
FUNDING IS PROPOSED AT A RECORD
HIGH. AT THIS TIME THE SAME TIME
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK VERY
HARD WITH SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENTS
WITH SCHOOL BOARDS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. TO ENSURE THAT
SCHOOLS CAN CONTINUE TO BE
SAFELY OPEN. HE DID HE CONTINUES
TO BE AN ISSUE OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES CONTINUED TO GET CALLS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO
ENSURE THAT YOU DO CHECKS ARE
GETTING. TO THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO REALLY. NEED THE
HELP AS WE SPEAK. I REALLY
APPRECIATE MISTER BLOOM BY NO MR
FONG FOR HOLDING A HEARING ON
WILDFIRES IN THE FALL WILDFIRES
CONTINUE TO BE A ROBUST PART OF
THIS JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
. MORE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARINGS ON THE- ALSO HEALTH
CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH ARE FRONT
CENTER IN JUST JANUARY PROPOSAL
WE REALLY APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS EFFORT TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND HEALTHCARE ACCESS.
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE STATE
WE KNOW THAT COUPLED WITH
INCREASED ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH WILL BE A MAJOR PRIORITY
IN DR RAM DEALERS SOME
COMMITTEE. AND LASTLY- WE HAVE
OUR CORRECTIONS AGENCY WHICH
CONTINUES TO SEE A DROP IN
POPULATION AND AS WE GO THROUGH
A DROP IN POPULATION WE ARE NOW
GRAPPLING WITH WHAT COMES NEXT
FOR OUR PRISON SYSTEM. IT OUR
BLUEPRINT THAT WE RELEASE THE
ASSEMBLY PROBABLY RELEASED IN
DECEMBER. WE HAD A MAJOR FOCUS
ON INFRASTRUCTURE. WHETHER THAT
WAS SCHOOL FACILITIES
TRANSPORTATION- WE KNOW THAT
WITH A SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
SURPLUS AGAIN THIS YEAR. WELL WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES. AND WE THINK THAT
THAT ARE FIT FOR STRUCTURE
INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE. IS A REALLY GOOD WAY TO
GO. WITHOUT LET ME TURN IT OVER
TO SEE IF ANY OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
ANY OTHER OPENING COMMENTS. OR
PRESSURE. I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
MISTER FOR COMPLETING THIS
HEARING AS WE KICK START THIS
YEAR'S ALLEGE THAT HAVE BUDGET
PROCESS- CERTAINLY THERE'S NO
SHORTAGE OF CRISES FACING
CALIFORNIANS. THAT WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THIS YEAR AND- AND THE
- AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND SO
AS THE LAUNDRY LIST THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT EDUCATION WELL FOR
PREVENTION INFRASTRUCTURE I
WOULD ADD SUPPLY CHAIN-
INVESTMENT. WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
BE ADDRESSING A MENTAL HEALTH
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS MENTIONED
BY THE CHAIR AS WELL- I WOULD
ALSO. THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT PERMANENT TAX RELIEF AS WELL
AS ADDRESSING PUBLIC SAFETY
WHICH IS BEGINNING TO BE A GROUP
OF GROWING CONCERN AMONGST- OF
AMONGST CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. SO I KNOW YOU AND I
SHARE A FOCUS ON OVERSIGHT I
KNOW THAT THAT THAT YEARS
COMMITTED TO THAT WE NEED TO
ENSURE. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
SPENDING OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS BUT
I WOULD CRTAINLY THAT THE
REVENUE COMING. TO SACRAMENTO IS
AND IS NOT OUR MONEY IT'S THE
MONEY EARNED BY- BY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS AND SO WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT- THERE IS A MEASURE
AT MEASURABLE RESULTS THAT WE
CAN SHOW- WITH THE INVESTMENTS
ARE BEING MADE SO- LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. ON ANOTHER
BUDGET YEAR HOPEFULLY WILL BE
LESS ATTIC AS AS- AS LAST YEAR
BUT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT BUT
BEFORE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE SAID
AS WELL AS WELL. ALONG WITH
ADMINISTRATION THANK MISTER. BY
SURE OTHER. COM I NOTHING IN THE
I WOULD AGAIN THANK YOU
HIGHLIGHTING AGAIN OVERSIGHT
LAST YEAR WE DID HAVE A HISTORIC
BUDGET WITH HISTORIC
EXPENDITURES I THINK- DURING
THIS YEAR WE'RE AS WE SEE THE
MONEY REACH OUT TO THE ALL
DIFFERENT PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MONEY IS BEING
SPENT PROPERLY AND AS YOU SAID
HAVING THEIR PROPER IMPACT I
THINK. CURRENTLY WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO- IDENTIFY AND SPEND A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER RESOURCES.
BUT IF YOU TALK TO MANY PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE THEY HAVEN'T. FELT THE
IMPACT YES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE IMPACTS COULD BE FELT
BY ALL THE PEOPLE. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO HELP. THEM WITH THAT
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO. THIS
ERICA LEAD. OR WITH THIRD PARTY
FINANCE. AFTERNOON CHARTING BY
STIR FONG AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ERICA LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO PRESENT. TO
THE COMMITTEE THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THIS BUDGET BUILDS ON
LAST YEAR'S EXTRAORDINARY
INVESTMENTS THAT. PROTECTED LIES
RIGHT KOBE NINETEEN THE PANDEMIC
BOB PROVIDED IMMEDIATE SUPPORTS
TO FAMILIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THE STATE IS
CONTINUING TO EXPERIENCE RECORD
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND THAT ON TOP
OF OUR DECADE OF FISCAL
PRUDENCE. REALLY GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON OUR PAST
INVESTMENTS AND STRENGTHEN THE
FOUNDATION FOR A FUTURE WITH A
CONTINUED FOCUS ON SUPPORTING A
MORE EVEN RECOVERY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THE CHURCH IS
MENTIONED. ON THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TAKES ON SOME OF THE STATE'S
BIGGEST CHALLENGES NAMELY COVER
NINETEEN CLIMATE CHANGE
HOMELESSNESS. THE COST OF LIVING
AND KEEPING OUR STREETS SAFE.
THE BUDGET PRESENTATION TODAY
BEGINS NOT SURPRISINGLY WITH
KOBE NINETEEN. TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET INCLUDED ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION FOR DIRECT
RESPONSE EFFORTS. AND SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE BUDGET HOWEVER
CALIFORNIA HAS DEALT WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES AROUND
THE DELTA VARIANTS AND NOW WE
FIND OURSELVES IN THE MIDST OF
THE OMICRON VARIANT.
ADDITIONALLY MORE CHILDREN ARE
NOW ELIGIBLE FOR VACCINES AND
THE STATE HAS REALLY RAMPED UP
ITS EFFORTS TO GET MORE CHILDREN
VACCINATED. IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE RISK OF SPREADING. THE
GOVERNOR ORIGINALLY REQUESTED
EARLY ACTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FOR COVERT RESPONSE
EFFORTS- WITH AN ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION IN SPENDING
AUTHORITY FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
HOWEVER THESE COSTS WERE
FINALIZED PRIOR TO KNOWING THE
FULL SCOPE OF ACTIVITIES
NECESSARY TO RESPOND TO A CRIME-
THE- THE ADMINISTRATION NOW ASKS
FOR AN ADDITIONAL. BILLION ON
TOP OF THAT TO SUPPORT EXPANDED
TESTING EFFORTS- TAKE SALARY
MAXINE AND BOOSTER SHOTS. AND
ADDRESS HOSPITAL AND MEDICAL
SEARCH. THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DETAILS OF
THIS EARLY BUDGET ACTION. ALONG
WITH OTHER COMPONENTS THAT I
WILL DISCUSS SHORTLY- THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO BE ABLE TO
SAVE OUR LIVES. BY IMMEDIATELY
AND EFFECTIVELY RESPONDING TO
THE EVER INVOLVING KOBE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUILDS ON SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENTS MADE IN PRIOR YEARS-
IT TOO FOR THEIR SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA PARENTS WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN AND TO REDUCE OVERALL
COST OF LIVING. THE BUDGET AS
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS ON TOP OF THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND SPOTS FROM LAST
YEAR OLD MARCHING TOWARDS A TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND- NUMBER BY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET IS ONE
BILLION TO IMPLEMENT THE FIRST
YEAR OF UNIVERSAL T. K. LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET MADE A ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOWN PAYMENT TO
EXPAND AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
PROGRAMS. AND THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR CONTINUES THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THREE POINT
FOUR BILLION I'M GOING FOR
EXTENDED DAY AND YOUR LONG
INSTRUCTION. AND ANOTHER ALMOST
BILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
INTEGRATING ARTS AND MUSIC INTO
ENRICHMENT PROGRAMS. IN HIGHER
EDUCATION THE BUDGET PROPOSES
MULTI YOUR CONTACTS WITH THE UC
AND CSU. AND A MULTI YEAR
ROADMAP FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THE STATE
WILL PROVIDE 5% BASED
AUGMENTATIONS FOR THE UC AND
CSU. AND SEGMENTS ARE EXPECTED
TO EXPAND ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY
ISSUES. AND CLOSE EQUITY GAPS
AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET FOR THE
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
OVERALL COST OF ATTENDANCE
THROUGH THE SECOND YEAR OF
FUNDING FOR STUDENT HOUSING THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION- AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND CAL GRANTS TO.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
FUNDING FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF A
REVAMPED MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. IN THE AREA OF
HEALTHCARE AS MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY ADVANCED
MULTIPLE MEASURES. IN RECENT
YEARS TO APPROVE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AS WELL AS ACCESS
TO THIS BUDGET CALIFORNIA WILL
BE THE FIRST STATE TO REALIZE
UNIVERSAL. ACCESS TO HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR ALL- REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND THIS
COVERS THE GAP OF ADULTS AGE
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY NINE.
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES WHILE ALSO
TACKLING CLIMATE CHANGE. FIRST
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TWO NEW
GREEN TAX CREDITS TO INSERT MOR
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES TO WORK
TOWARD MITIGATING THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. ADDITIONALLY WE
PROPOSE A WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
AROUND THE CAMP PRODUCTION. ON
THE THEME OF THE METAL THAT'S
PLENTIFUL IN CALIFORNIA AND
VITAL FOR ELECTRIC CAR BATTERIES
CALIFORNIA IS POISED TO BECOME A
GLOBAL LEADER IN DEPLOYING
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND TECHNOLOGY
TO PRODUCE LITHIUM. ALONG WITH
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY AND BECOME
A WORLD CLASS BATTERY
MANUFACTURER LEADING TO GET
JOBS- EXPANDING ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY IN THE SALTON SEA
REGION AND CALIFORNIA MORE
BROADLY. IN ADDITION THE BUDGET
INCLUDES OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
RELATED INVESTMENTS TO PREPARE
AND PROTECT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL SPUR MORE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL LIKELY WILL LIKEWISE DRIVE
MORE ECONOMIC GROWTH AND JOB
CREATION DURING RECOVERY- ADAMS
LAST YEAR SMALL BUSINESS PACKAGE
THIS YEAR THE BUDGET PROPOSES
REMOVING LIMITS I'M NOT
OPERATING LOSS AND TAX CREDIT
SOMETHING THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED
DURING THE RECESSION- EXPANDING
STATE TAX CONFORMITY TO QUALIFY
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS AND
VENUES THAT RECEIPT OF FEDERAL
RELIEF FRIENDS. SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESSES ON THE WAIT LIST FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. AND LASTLY THE BUDGET
INCLUDES THREE BILLION TO REDUCE
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TRUST
FUND THAT. WHILE SUPPORTING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES IS VITAL FOR
STATES CONTINUED ECONOMIC GROWTH
WE MUST ALSO INVEST IN OUR
DIVERSE WORKFORCE. AS ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY THE LEGISLATURE THE
MINISTRATION HAVE DEVELOPED A
FRAMEWORK TO EXTENSIBLE MODEL
PAID SICK LEAVE AS PART OF AN
EARLY ACTION. THIS WILL PROTECT
OUR WORKERS THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR WORKPLACE FROM THE SPREAD
OF COBIT. FRAMEWORK ALSO
SUPPORTS OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
ADDING MANY OF THE PROPOSED
BUSINESS- SUPPORTS- I JUST
PRESENTED ADDITIONALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF SMALL BUSINESS THROUGH
THE BUDGET. IN ADDITION TO THE
REQUEST FOR EARLY ACTION FOR
PAID SICK LEAVE THE BUDGET
PROPOSES STRATEGIES TO TRAIN
WORKERS FOR JOBS. THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND TO MEET A
GROWING DEMAND FOR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AS WELL AS TEACHERS. AND
BUILDING ON LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS THE BUDGET
INVEST OVER TWENTY BILLION AND
ALIGNED EFFORTS. IN CLIMATE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING ENERGY
AND HEALTH TO RESPOND TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND MOVE FORWARD
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. FOR
THE SECOND TIME I WILL HIGHLIGHT
TWO OF THE MANY IMPORTANT
PROPOSALS. ON THE BUDGET
INCLUDES NINE POINT ONE BILLION
IN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THAT
WILL SUPPORT CONTINUED
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NATION'S.
FIRST ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AS WELL AS REGIONAL
TRANSIT AND RAIL PROJECTS
BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN PROJECTS AND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROJECTS. IS
FUNDS WILL YIELD THOUSANDS OF
NEW JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
HOUSING THE BUDGET INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION TO ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ESPECIALLY NEAR DOWNTOWN
AREAS- AND AREAS NEAR TRANSIT
AND SERVICES IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SO IN CONCLUSION THIS
IS A VERY QUICK SYNOPSIS OF SOME
OF THAT SIGNIFICANT AND EXCITING
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AS ALWAYS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SERVES AS A LAUNCHING PAD
FOR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
SPRING STARTING WITH OUR EARLY
ACTION CLASS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO QUESTIONS-
AFTER US THE L. A. OKAY STAGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT GONNA
MISTER PANIC. EIGHT MONTHS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. MISTER CHAIR AND
MR VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT THE L. A.
O. FOR TODAY'S HEARING. I WILL
WALK THROUGH A HANDOUT THAT I
PUT UP ON THE SCREEN AND ALSO
THAT YOU HOPEFULLY HAVE AND IT'S
AVAILABLE AT ELADIO DOT CA DOT
GOV. FOR ANYONE FOLLOWING ALONG
AND AFTER MY REMARKS MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WILL BE HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE- I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
IF IT'S ALL RIGHT BEFORE GOING
INTO THE HAND OUT. THAT TODAY
YOU'LL HEAR ME DISCUSS THE
ESTIMATED SURPLUS STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT OR THE GAL
THAT IS AGAIN SORRY. OUR
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAJOR
PROPOSALS AND THEN A BRIEF WORD
ON THE BUDGET CONDITION AND
RESERVES THROUGHOUT THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK YOU'LL SEE A
THEME EMERGE THAT WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO KEEP IN MIND HOW TO
PRESERVE LEGISLATIVE
FLEXIBILITY. AND HOW TO CONTINUE
TO STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S FISCAL
RESILIENCE ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT
OF THE ONGOING UNCERTAINTY
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC RISING
AND- VARIOUS OTHER CHALLENGES
THAT ARE OUT THERE. AND I JUST
YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
RESILIENCE AND RESERVES I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSCORE THAT IT'S NOT FOR
THEIR OWN SAKE IT'S NOT FOUR OR
OR AN ABSTRACT NOTION OF FISCAL
PRUDENCE. IT'S SO THAT THE STATE
CAN REMAIN IN A STRONG POSITION
TO UPHOLD THE COMMITMENTS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
PREVIOUSLY. AND SO THAT THE
STATE CAN SUSTAIN VITAL PROGRAMS
IN THE EVENT OF ANOTHER
UNEXPECTED SHOCKER DOWNTURNS. SO
IS THAT ALL JUMPED INTO THE TO
THE HAND OUT HERE MOVING TO PAGE
ONE- THE FIGURE ON THE FIRST
PAGE. HERE DISPLAYS HOW THE
GOVERNOR ALLOCATES THE
DISCRETIONARY SURPLUS AS YOU
KNOW WE RUN OUR OWN CALCULATIONS
AND WE FOUND THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD ACCORDING TO OUR
MEASUREMENTS AT TWENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR DISCRETIONARY
SURPLUS TO ALLOCATE. THIS IS
SOMEWHAT HIGHER THAN THE TWENTY
ONE BILLION IN DISCRETIONARY
SURPLUS IDENTIFIED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. NOW SINCE WE
BOTH BOTH OF OUR OFFICES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA-
FOLLOW. SIMILAR METHODOLOGY FOR
CALCULATING THE SURPLUS I'LL
POINT OUT THAT WHERE WE DIFFER
IS THAT IN- SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE ITEMS THAT WE COUNT AS
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING WHICH
MEANS IT CONTRIBUTES TO THE
SURPLUS. THE ADMINISTRATION
COUNTS AS PART OF THE STATE'S
EXISTING SPENDING BASE SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN NOTABLE ONE IS WE
CONSIDER THE THREE AND A HALF
BILLION OR SO- PROPOSED
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURES
SPENDING- IN THAT PACKAGE AS
DISCRETIONARY. THUS INCREASING
THE SURPLUS BY THAT MUCH IN THAT
WHERE IS THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDED THAT AS PART OF THE
SPENDING BASELINE. SO WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH IS
REASONABLE. WE CAN OUT- SUCH
AMOUNTS AS PART OF DISCRETIONARY
SURPLUS OUT OF DEFERENCE TO YOU
IN THE LEGISLATURE IN OTHER
WORDS FOR US IT'S NOT JUST A
TECHNICAL ACCOUNTING DIFFERENCE.
OUR APPROACH YOUR RECOGNIZES IN
ORDER SPENDING. THE LEGISLATURE
MUST MAKE AN APPROACH. MUST
APPROPRIATE THE FUNDS FIRST SO
YOU MAY DECIDE THAT YOU CHOOSE
TO END IT HERE TO THESE PREVIOUS
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE REFLECTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT IT'S
STILL A CHOICE ON YOUR PART. AND
THAT'S WHY WE RECOGNIZE IT AS
SUCH. SO WHEN I TURNED TO THE
TWO FIGURES ON THE SLIDE- THE
TOP ONE IS SHOWING THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION OF THE
TWENTY NINE BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS. US SEVENTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION OF THAT IS GOING
FOR A ONE TIMER TEMPORARY
PROGRAMMATIC SPENDING WE
CONSIDER THREE YEARS OR LESS TO
BE A TEMPORARY. PROGRAM
COMMITMENTS. SIX POINT TWO
BILLION IS FOR REVENUE
REDUCTIONS THREE POINT ONE
BILLION GOES TO THE STATE'S
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE THE
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY. TWO BILLION. IN
ONGOING SPENDING SO I WOULD NOTE
THAT WE ESTIMATE OUT WILL
INCREASE TO OVER FIVE BILLION BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
AND THEN THERE IS FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY BILLION IN DEBT REPAYMENT
ON TOP OF THE FOUR BILLION YEN.
DARREN LIABILITY PAYMENTS
REQUIRED BY PROPOSITION TWO.
ALSO I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE BILLION IN GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVES WHICH WE INCLUDE IN
THAT- THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT SAFETY THE SFUAND THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE. THE SECOND
FIGURE HERE IS REFERENCING THE
PROFIT PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SIDE OF THE BUDGET. AND ARE IT
WITHIN THIS SIDE. EARLY BECAUSE
OF HIGHER REVENUES RESULTING IN
A HIGHER MINIMUM GUARANTEED
THERE IS ALMOST EIGHTEEN BILLION
IN PROPOSED NEW SPENDING. AFTER
COVERING THE ROUGHLY FOUR
BILLION CAUGHT IN COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A FIVE POINT 3%
COLA. B. THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
ALLOCATING ABOUT THIRTEEN
BILLION AND IN RESOURCES AS
SHOWN IN THIS FIGURE SEVEN
BILLION FOR ONE TIME ACTIVITIES.
THREE POINT FOUR BILLION FOR THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM WHICH WAS INITIATED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. THERE'S A
ONE POINT TWO BILLION ADJUSTMENT
FOR DISTRICTS- WRIST IN RESPONSE
TO THE DECLINE OVERALL DECLINING
ENROLLMENT- EFFECTS THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE ON THEIR FUNDING
OTHERWISE. AND THEN ONE POINT
ONE POINT THREE BILLION YEAH
AND- OTHER ONGOING. INCREASES IN
SPENDING. AND LIKE WHAT THE
OTHER SIDE- JUST NOTE THERE'S-
ALMOST TEN BILLION IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT RESERVE
UNDER THE RULES OF PROPOSITION
TWO SO THAT'S THE LARGEST
BALANCE- TO DATE IN THAT- IN
THAT RESERVE. THE WORD ON THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT-
WHICH AFFECTS HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN USE REVENUES
THAT EXCEED A CERTAIN THRESHOLD
- AND WHETHER THE STATE HAS
REQUIREMENTS STEMMING FROM
EXCEEDING THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT IS A TWO
YEAR CALCULATION. AND SO FOR THE
PRIOR YEAR IN THE CURRENT YEAR
SO TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REFLECTS THAT STATE
APPROPRIATIONS EXCEED THE LIMIT
BY TWO POINT SIX BILLION
COMBINED ACROSS THOSE TWO YEARS
- THAT. ACCESS OR THE AMOUNT OF
REQUIREMENTS FROM THIS WHICH
WOULD ACTUALLY BE MORE THAN THAT
EXCEPT FOR THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES ABOUT SIX POINT THREE
BILLION IN PROPOSALS THAT MEETS
OUR REQUIREMENTS THUS LOWERING
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THE LIMIT BY THAT AMOUNT. THE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE A SPECIFIC PROPOSAL FOR
DEALING WITH THESE ACCESS
REVENUES AND INDICATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL PUT FORWARD
A PLAN AT THE TIME OF THE MAY
REVISION. HERE YOU KNOW WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR
MEETING THIS HOUR REQUIREMENT
BEFORE ME. THE MAIN REASON FOR
THAT IS THAT DELAYING THE
FORMATION OF THE PLAN REDUCES
LEGISLATIVE FLEXIBILITY. FOR
INSTANCE IF REVENUES CONTINUE TO
OUTPACE BUDGET ESTIMATES IN THE
LEGISLATURE PREFERRED TO ADDRESS
A PORTION OF THE OF THE
REQUIREMENT COMING FROM FROM THE
CELL BY LOWERING TAXES. AND
REALLY EARLIER ACTION WOULD BE
BETTER THAN WAITING UNTIL MAY IN
ORDER FOR IT TO AFFECT YOU EIGHT
THAT TYPE OF THE POLICY. AS WE
LOOK TO THE TWENTY TWENTY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET YEAR. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REFLECTS ROOM OF ABOUT
WERE UNDER THE LIMIT BY ABOUT
FIVE POINT SEVEN BILLION- AND
HERE AGAIN WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THERE ARE AROUND TWELVE BILLION
IN PROPOSALS THAT REDUCED
REVENUES ARE APPROPRIATIONS
SUBJECT TO THE LIMIT SO THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT- PART OF THE-
OVERALL PROPOSAL. TAKING IT IN
ITS TOTALITY THERE IT YOU KNOW
AND LOOKING AT THE TWENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HAS ABOUT
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSALS THAT ADDRESS CELL
REQUIREMENTS. WITH THE OTHER
TWELVE BILLION OR SO IN
PROPOSAL'S NOT ADDRESSING CELL
THE CELL REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
EXCLUDABLE FROM THE CELL. THESE
INCLUDE EIGHT POINT FIVE BILLION
IN- IN SPENDING AND THEN THREE
POINT ONE BILLION THAT GOES TO
THE S. S. B. U. WHICH IS AS WE
NOTED BEFORE IT DOES NOT- IS NOT
EXCLUDABLE FROM THE CELL JUST
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST GOING INTO
THE S. AND P. YOU SEE. WHAT THIS
ALL MEANS IS THAT IF YOU WEIGH
YOUR CHOICES ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS BROADLY SPEAKING ARE
IN ORDER TO KEEP APPROPRIATIONS
BELOW THE LIMIT IN TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
ANY OF THE SEVENTEEN BILLION YEN
SALIX MOVABLE PROPOSALS- THAT
THEY GOT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OPTS TO REJECT REALLY MUST BE
REPLACED BY ANOTHER ALLOCATION.
THAT IS SELL EXCLUDABLE ALSO.
I'M SORRY KIND OF WHITE IT TO
THE BIG. ESSENTIALLY ON THE
OTHER HAND ANY OF THE TWELVE
BILLION THAT ARE NOT EXCLUDABLE
. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE WERE TO
REJECT SOME OF THOSE YOU COULD
REPLACE THOSE WITH OTHER NOT
EXCLUDABLE- ALLOCATIONS
WARRICK'S WILL DOUBLE ALLOCATION
SO IN A WAY HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY WITH THAT SUCH THAT
SIDE OF THE- TOTAL- THEN. ALL
RIGHT LET ME JUST TURN BRIEFLY
HERE TO THE- COMMENTS WE HAVE ON
THE GOVERNOR'S SPENDING
PROPOSALS OVERALL WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO KEEP
IN MIND THE MAGNITUDE OF LAST
YEAR'S COMMITMENTS AND DEDICATE
SOME PORTION OF THE EARLY PART
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS TO
CHECKING IN ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE CHOICES.
JULY IN SOMEWHAT CONSISTENT WITH
REMARKS MADE BY THE CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR IN THE OPENING
STATEMENTS RELATED TO THIS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT CREATING NEW
PROGRAMS WE'RE SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDING EXT EXISTING ONES. WE
THINK IT MAY BE APPROPRIATE TO
BE YOU THE ONGOING PANDEMIC IN
AS AS A LONG TERM ISSUE AND
CONSIDER THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS RECOGNIZED.
THIS POTENTIAL REALITY. THE NEXT
TWO PAGES I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THROUGH IN DETAIL AT ALL- BUT
THEY REALLY ARE JUST A LISTING
OF SOME OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS
AND SOME OF OUR- ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON THOSE AND WE'VE BEEN
. STARTING TO GET OUT OUR
ANALYSIS ON VARIOUS OF THESE NOW
BUT YOU'D SEE UNDER EACH OF THE
PROPOSED. MAJOR PROPOSALS THAT.
SOME OF OUR COMMENTS REALLY YOU
KNOW IT ECHO THE THEMES THAT
I'VE BEEN MENTIONING. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
FOR EXAMPLE. THIS SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTING MANY NEW PROGRAMS
AND REQUIREMENTS IN. SO IT'S YOU
KNOW THEIR CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT
EVEN MORE NEW PROGRAMS IS
PROBABLY LIMITED. WE RECOMMEND
THEREFORE FUNDING FEWER OF THE
NEW ONE TIME PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR IN PRIORITIZING THOSE
TO DRESS YOUR PRIORITIES AND THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS THAT THAT
CANNOT BE ADDRESSED WITH WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND TO SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO PAGES ON THE
MAJOR PROPOSALS MERIT JUST LIKE
TO CLOSE ON THE LAST TWO PAGES
YOU'RE MENTIONING OUR VIEWS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS IT
RELATES TO THE STATE'S OVERALL
BUDGET CONDITION. YOU MAY RECALL
IN RECENT PREVIOUS YEARS WE'VE
DESCRIBED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
REVENUE ESTIMATES AS POSSIBLE
THOUGH A BIT CAUTIOUS RELATIVE
TO OURS. NOW IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
MUCH HIGHER THAN BEFORE OVER THE
THREE YEAR BUDGET WINDOW- THAT
YOU KNOW IS CONSIDERED. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS RAISED
REVENUE ESTIMATES BY FORTY ONE
BILLION FROM THE BUDGET ACT AND
AT THIS POINT THERE ARE MUCH
CLOSER TO WHAT WE WOULD CONSIDER
THAT MEDIAN LIKELIHOOD OUTCOME
OR MIDDLE OF THE ROAD SCENARIO.
AND SO YOU KNOW WHILE WELL THESE
ESTIMATES ARE REASONABLE THEY'RE
CLOSE TO OURS YOU KNOW SO WE
THINK THEY'RE REASONABLE- THE
YOU KNOW THE FACT IS BY BY USING
A HIGHER REVENUE ESTIMATE
THERE'S JUST LESS LIKELIHOOD FOR
AN UPSIDE ADJUSTMENT- UPSIDE
REVISION LATER ON SUCH AS
SOMETHING TO BE COGNIZANT OF.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY REALLY
BECOMES IMPORTANT WHEN WE BEGAN
LOOKING THROUGH TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. MULTI YOU'RE A
GENERAL FUND FORECAST BECAUSE IT
THE MULTI YEAR FORECAST SHOWS
NEGATIVE STFU BALANCES. YEAH
AND- BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE FORECAST TO
RISE AND SO ESSENTIALLY THIS
MEANS THAT- THE ADMINISTRATION
SPENDING PROPOSALS EXCEED ITS
OWN ESTIMATES OF THE STATE'S
FUTURE BUDGET CAPACITY. AND SO
THAT'S- YOU KNOW STE. ONE
COMMENT. FINALLY ON THE FINAL
PAGE HERE WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
ON RESERVES FIRST I WILL JUST
POINT OUT HAT WE DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN THE GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVES WHICH AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING IT INCLUDES THAT THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
THE SFU IN THE STICKING OUT
RESERVE WE DIFFERENTIATE THAT
GROUP FROM THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE. WELL THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT RESERVE IS VERY HELPFUL
FOR MAINTAINING EDUCATION
FUNDING IN A DOWN YEAR THOSE
BALANCES REALLY WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP ADDRESS A
BUDGET PROBLEM SO WE DON'T THINK
OF THEM AS GENERALLY AVAILABLE
FOR GENERAL PURPOSE IN THAT SAME
WAY. AND WHO AS WE LOOK AT THE
TOTAL OF THE GENERAL PURPOSE
RESERVE THAT ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
BILLION. NOMINALLY THAT'S VERY
HIGH HISTORICALLY HIGH BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THEM AS A SHARE OF
THE BUDGET WHICH I THINK IS THE
IMPORTANT WAY TO LOOK AT THEM
THEY WOULD REMAIN SOMEWHAT BELOW
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. AND SO FOR
THAT REASON WE DO THINK THAT. IT
WARRANT YOUR CONSIDERATION
ACCORDING. TO GET MORE INTO THE
GENERAL PURPOSE RESERVES ON AN
OPTIONAL BASIS. SO I'LL STOP
THERE AND BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
. GREAT THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GOING TO TURN OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS CALL. UP VOTE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL ALSO
WITH ELIO AND THEN GO TO THE
PREMIER FINANCE IN TERMS OF WHAT
YOU JUST SAID- ABOUT- WHICH
FUTURE MULTI YOUR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND THEN YOUR YOUR
CAUTION TO US ABOUT- THE NEED
FOR MORE OVERSIGHT AND- FOCUSING
ON ON. THAT INSTEAD OF CREATING
ADDITIONAL NEW PROGRAMS- I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TALK EAT
EAT YOU GOTTA HINTED AT IT BUT I
GUESS THEY WILL ASK MORE BLUNTLY
THERE AGAINST THAT'S THE SENATE.
MEMBERS OF OVER A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME WITH THE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND WHAT THE BUT THE
GOVERNOR PRESS FOR POST. WELL I
THINK THERE'S JUST A CONCERN IN
THE SENSE THAT- YOU KNOW THE
MULTI YEAR FORECAST SHOULD
REPRESENT OUR- BEST ESTIMATES OF
WHAT WE THINK THE FUTURE HOLDS
AND SO IF THE MULTI YEAR
FORECAST IS SHOWING NOT JUST AN
OPERATING DEFICIT. WHERE CURRENT
YEAR REVENUES. PRINT YOUR
EXPENDITURES BUT ACTUALLY A
NEGATIVE SFC YOU BALANCE. HELLO
THAT'S ACTUALLY A BUDGET THAT
YOU WOULD BE ALLOWED TO PASS
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION'S OUR
BALANCED BUDGET REQUIREMENT SO
WHAT IT SAYS TO ME IS THAT
THERE'S WE'RE WE'RE STARTING OFF
FROM A PLACE WHERE WE ASSUME
THAT THERE WILL BE A CHANGE FROM
THE CURRENT FORECAST THAT EITHER
REVENUES WILL BE HIGHER. OR
EXPENDITURES WILL BE LOWER AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY POSSIBLE- BUT
AS I SAID THE REVENUES HAVE BEEN
ADJUSTED UPWARD WHICH IS VERY
REASONABLE BUT IT JUST MEANS
THAT THERE'S LESS- THE CONTROL
FOR AN ADDITIONAL UPSIDE
REVISION AFTER YOU'VE ALREADY
MOVED THEM UP TO MORE OF THIS.
MEDIA AND LIKELIHOOD OUT. SO
YEAH I THINK I THINK THAT'S-
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THAT MR FONG
THAT'S SPOKEN LIKE A TRUE
ANALYST HE GIVEN A LOT OF WORDS
ON THAT ONE- AB. S. AS
ESSENTIALLY THERE'S A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS AND WE NEED TO BE I
GUESS THE BROADER I GUESS THE
CONCLUSION IS THAT YOU WANT YOU
WOULD RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
MAINTAIN SOME FLEXIBILITY.
INTERNET IS IF IT'S IF IT'S IN
TERMS OF LOOKING OUT TO THE
FUTURE. YES WE THINK SO OKAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT THANKS THANK
YOU. MOVING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I'M LOOKING AT IT
THROUGH THE LENS OF WHAT THE L.
LEO HAS SAID BUT CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT IT FROM THE CRISES
THAT THE CHAIR AS OUTLINED I
FIRST WANT TO TALK ABOUT I GUESS
DROUGHT ANDIN WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AT CERTAINLY. I
AM. I HAVE BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN
ABOUT THE NEED TO ACCELERATE WAR
WATER STORAGE IN OUR STATE THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN PROMOTING A
SIX BILLION DOLLAR DROP PACKAGE.
IN THIS PROPOSAL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
BUDGET YEAR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION HASN'T BEEN FULLY
FLESHED OUT YET BUT THERE ISN'T.
ANY NEW FUNDING FOR WATER
STORAGE AND I JUST KINDA WANT TO
UNDERSTAND AS THE GOVERNOR
TALKED ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AS
THE GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT LONG
TERM PLANNING WHERE IS THE
URGENCY I GUESS WHEN IT COMES
TO. ADDITIONAL WATER STORAGE.
SURE THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG- I YEAH THE
FIRM THERE'S A AN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
ON TOP OF THE ONE BILLION THAT
WAS. ALLOCATED AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S- BUDGET AGREEMENT THE
TOTAL FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS PACKAGE- AS TO STORAGE
I'M GONNA TURN THAT QUESTION
OVER FOR MORE DETAILS TO MY
COLLEAGUES- CRYSTAL. THANK YOU.
SH GOOD AFTERNOON CRYSTAL SURE
TO WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO WATER
RESILIENCY IN THE STATE- AS
OUTLINED BY THE GOVERNOR'S WATER
PORTFOLIO- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS REFLECTIVE OF THAT
APPROACH BY CONTINUING TO
INVEST- INCLUDING THAT. THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION BUT
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE FOR THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- FOR WATER
CONSERVATION GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS- THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE EXISTING PROPOSITION ONE.
FUNDING FOR WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS COLLECTIVELY HELP US
TOWARD- OUR GOALS OF PROVIDING A
HIGHER WATER RELIABILITY AND
QUALITY- AND SO I OULD JUST I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO-
APPROACH WATER RESILIENCY FROM
THAT COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
SHOULD DEFINITELY SEE- WATER
STORAGE AS BEING A PART OF THAT
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY. SO PROP
ONE WAS ALREADY THERE AND I
GUESS THAT'S UNANSWERED AS GIVEN
TO ME A LOT BUT SETTING ASIDE
PROP ONE. WHICH IS STILL NEEDS
TO BE ALLOCATED IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ACCELERATE. THE WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS THAT ARE PENDING
BEFORE'S BEFORE THE STATE. THERE
IS NOT EDUCATIONAL FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET AT AS I
MENTIONED- WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT PROVIDING
INVESTMENTS IN SOME OF THESE
OTHER AREAS INCLUDING WATER
CONSERVATION AND INFRASTRUCTURE
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- AS WE-
TACKLE SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH. DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE- BUT I MUST BE TO
PROVIDE JUST A LITTLE BIT OF AN
UPDATE ON THE EXISTING
PROPOSITION ONE FUNDING WHICH I
THINK IS- IMPORTANT-
SPECIFICALLY THE SEVEN PROPOSED
PROP ONE PROJECTS THAT AND
RECENTLY PASSED. A KEY HURDLE
AND RECEIVING FEASIBLE BY THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION I'M
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AND SO
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THOSE PROJECT
PROPONENTS ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING INTO- COMPLETING THE SOME
OF THE FINAL ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS AND SOME OF THE OTHER
I'M REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE. THAT
ARE NEEDED AND SO- YOU KNOW THE
TIMELINE HAS HAS- BEEN BEEN
MOVING AT A PACE THAT I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW HAS HAS
TAKEN SEVERAL YEARS THESE ARE.
LOCALLY DRIVEN PROJECTS THAT
HAVE QUITE A FEW I'M A DIFFERENT
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES. AND HOW IT
IS I'M INCLUDING PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTING AND THAT SORT OF
THING SO THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT. THOSE
THOSE SEVEN WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS- THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION.
LOOK AYE AYES I JUST I HOPE
DEMONSTRATION WILL FAST TRACK
THOSE PROJECTS I HOPE THAT AS
THE WE DEVELOP OUR BUDGET IN THE
AND THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
WOULD PUT SOME MORE MONEY A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
INTO GETTING THOSE PROJECTS
COMPLETED ESPECIALLY AS WE
ENTER. INTO ANOTHER DROUGHT
YEAR- JUMPING TO WILDFIRE AND
THE CHAIR AGAIN MENTIONED THIS
IN AND- HE IS CORRECT- WE NEED
TO- REACH OUR GOAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF A
TREATMENT. LET ME FIRST ASK IN
AND OUR LAST OVERSIGHT HEARING.
THAT WE HAD IN DECEMBER- THERE
WAS DISCUSSIONS. ABOUT REPORTS
ON THE UP OF WHAT THE STATE HAS
DONE- THAT WAS REQUIRED UNDER AB
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE DELIVERED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WE WERE TOLD.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WE GET
THOSE REPORTS BY JANUARY THE
FIRST BECAUSE JANUARY. AND I
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVEN'T
THEM SO IS THERE UPDATE WHEN WE
WOULD GET THOSE. REPORTS ONLINE-
WHAT THE STATE HAS DONE WHEN IT
COMES TO WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT AND
PREVENTION. REQUIRED BY. LAW ALL. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG IS
THERE ANY OF THEIR STEVEN BANKS
AND COULD YOU PLEASE RESPOND
MISTER. GOOD AFTERNOON STEVEN
BEDS WITH BARBARA FINANCED- I'M
SORRY I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT DATE
FOR YOU RIGHT NOW WE ARE WORKING
WITH THAT THAT'S RESOURCES
AGENCY IN ITS DEPARTMENTS TO GET
INFORMATION PUT TOGETHER AND
READY TO THE L. A. O. N. AND
LET'S STAFF. IN RESPONSE TO
THAT. SO THE REPORTS ARE.
SUBMITTED FOR THE PARTS ARE DONE. I DON'T BELIEVE THE REPORTS
YOU'RE REFERRING TO ARE COMPLETE
THIS POINT OKAY. AND I THINK
THIS GOES BACK TO. THE YOU KNOW
THE NEED FOR OVERSIGHT WHEN WE
ARE ALLOCATING FUNDS BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S BEING DONE AND
THESE REPORTS ARE A CRITICAL- TO
IT TO UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS CURRENT
YEARS BUT- THAT NOT KERN YOU'RE
OUTSIDE. THAT THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL HAS SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS SO IT'S SIX HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THIS UPCOMING YEAR
AND SIX SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AFTER THAT. VOTE THIS PAST YEAR
WE DEDICATED ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
SO WHY DO WE GO FROM ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION TO SIX HUNDRED
MILLION. IS THERE A REASON WHY.
SO LAST YEAR'S PACKAGE ACTUALLY
INCLUDED ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'M FISCAL YEAR
THAT'S PART OF THE WORLD QUITE
FIVE BE REFERENCING AND THEN FOR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR INCLUDED AT JUST UNDER
BILLION DOLLARS- SO WHAT WHAT WE
HAVE DONE IS ASSESSED KIND OF.
WHAT WE THINK IS BILLS THAT IT
CHIEF OF ALL BUT AMBITIOUS LEVEL
FUNDING TO CONTINUE THE SAME
PROGRAM PRIMARILY THE SAME
PROGRAMS THAT RAN LAST YEAR'S
PACKAGE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
CONTINUING THE CHOICES LAST
YEAR'S PACKAGE INCLUDED
CONTINUOUS PREPARATION OF TURNER
NINE DOLLARS EACH YEAR AFTER.
RIGHT SOME ONGOING FUNDING FOR.
FOREST HEALTH AND- FIRE
PREVENTION. THREE TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE SO THAT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION REFERENCED INCLUDES THAT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. AND THEN-
PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND. THAT WE BELIEVE IT
IS- LIKE I SAID INVESTORS IN A
T. MOBILE LEVEL FUNDING TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THIS PACKAGE SO THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION IS TWO
HUNDRED FROM GIGI R. F. AND FOUR
HUNDRED OF THE GENERAL FUND.
CORRECT OKAY. I THINK IT'S JUST.
LIKE WE HAVE TO ACCELERATE OUR-
FIRE WILDFIRE FUEL MANAGEMENT.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE OUR STATE
AND TO GO FROM. ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN A CALENDAR
YEAR TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO RE EVALUATE- IN TERMS OF
JUMPING TO. THE TAX RELIEF
MEASURES I KNOW THAT THAT MAY BE
ABLE EARLY ACTION ITEM BUT WHAT
WE CAN DISCUSS IN EARLY ACTION
BUT I WAS WONDERING IF THERE'S
BEEN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- I KNOW
THAT WITH THE LAST TIME WE TALK
ABOUT CONFORMITY THE TIMING WAS
WAS OFF AND A LOT OF ACCOUNTANTS
AND IN SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE
TRYING TO FILE- WERE CAUGHT UP
IN AND JUST THE- THE CONFUSION
THERE SO I WAS WONDERING IN
TERMS OF ALL THESE. YOU KNOW
PASSED ENTITY TAX CONFORMITY IS
AND THE DEDUCTIONS THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED- IS IT ARE THERE
PLANS TO EXPAND THESE FRAMEWORKS
IN EARLY ACTION SO THAT
TAXPAYERS CAN MEET THE UPCOMING
MARCH FIFTEENTH TAX FILING
DEADLINE. YES I'M GONNA TURN THE
QUESTION OVER TO J. CHAMBERLAIN
FOR SOME DETAILS. YES ST GENERAL
PUBLIC FINANCE SO YEAH- WE ARE-
THE EASY I'LL- I BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS RIGHT NOW
THAT WOULD. ENACT THOSE
DEPLOYED- TO UNLOCK THOSE
PROVISIONS AND AFFECTED TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TAX YEAR THE TO ENACT
THOSE PRIOR TO MARCH FIFTEENTH.
BY THE DEADLINE OKAY UP ICE I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT- IN
TERMS OF THAT THE YOU AYE DADDY.
AND THIS STEP THE STATUS OF THE
STATE- FUND. WHAT IS THE CURRENT
ESTIMATE OF FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS
FROM THE STATE FUND I UNDERSTAND
IT MAYBE NORTH OF A BILLION
DOLLARS BUT IS THERE DO YOU HAVE
AN ESTIMATE. ON THE STATE FOR
ALL OF THE STATE SIDE. CHARLTON
A QUESTION TO CHRIS COOK. CHRIS
COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I DON'T HAVE THAT FIGURE OF THE
STATE DEAD IN FRONT OF ME- I
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH WITH STAFF
AND PROVIDE THAT NUMBER FOR YOU
. THEY'LL BE- THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL I UNDERSTAND IT TO BE
ABOUT. A LITTLE OVER A BILLION
EVEN THOUGH THE FULL ET DE-
FRAUD NUMBER IS PROBABLY ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS. AND SO
WHEN THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO
PAY DOWN THE U. I. DEBT. BY
THREE BILLION MY UNDERSTANDING
IT'S A BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. YEAR AND THEN
IT'S A PLEDGE TO DO TWO BILLION
DOLLARS THE FOLLOWING YEAR IS
THAT CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY SO THEN THE BILLION WOULD
PROBABLY COVER THAT THE
FRAUDULENT PAYMENTS. IN THE
STATE OF THE STATE FUND AND THEN
ARE THERE ANY ASSURANCES THAT
THE TWO BILLION WOULD
MATERIALIZE IN THE FOLLOWING
YEAR. OR IS THAT SOMETHING WE'RE
JUST GONNA HAVE TO HOLD YOU
GUYS. ACCOUNTABLE FOR. WELL
THAT'S A COMMITTEES SIMILAR TO
OTHER- YEARS. BUDGETARY EARLY
WE'RE SCORING THAT IN THE IN
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE AND SO
THAT'S THE COMMITMENT TO MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT. AND THOSE WILL
BE THAT AND AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE PROCESS THIS YEAR- THAT WILLBE DISCUSSED FURTHER BY THE
COMMITMENT AT THIS TIME IS TEND
TO INVEST THAT TWO BILLION IN
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE. OKAY IN
TERMS OF THE INFILL FUNDS THAT
WORD TO YOU- TO INCENTIVIZE AT
INFILL DEVELOPMENT. HOW IS THE
FORMULA GOING TO BE DEVELOPED IS
THERE GOING TO BE IS IT IS IT
GOING TO GO TO THE L. A. AND- IN
THE BAY AREA WHICH OF CERTAINLY
HAS NEEDS BUT I WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW- URBAN CENTERS IN
IN IN IN THE CENTER VALLEY. AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE WOULD
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE FUNDS
TO. YES CHRIS COOK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN- FOR
THE IG FINDS- FURTHER DETAILS
WILL BE. RELEASED AS PART OF THE
TRAILER BILL PROCESS BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING. THE AND
FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO BE- ISSUED
SIMILAR TO HOW THEY WERE FOR THE
PRIOR IG PROGRAMS- BUT ONE THING
TO NOTICE IS THAT- WITH THE I AG
FUNDS MORE RECENTLY THERE IS AN-
URBAN. I AM SORRY A RURAL SET
ASIDE FOR THESE FUNDS. AND SO
THERE IS A RECOGNITION THAT
THERE'S NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO PROVIDE THESE INFILL
DOLLARS. AND FURTHER AT HCD IS
GOOD ABOUT- BEING COGNISANT OF
THE NEEDS THROUGHOUT AND THEY
TRY TO EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTE
THESE DOLLARS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IN ALL REGIONS. YEAH AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT- IN
TERMS OF SUPPLY CHAIN I KNOW- I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH IS- BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
THIS SPACE. NOW IN THE LAST.
PORTS HEARING I BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATED THAT
THERE WOULD BE SOME DECISION BY
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH ABOUT EXCESS
LAND TO BE USED TO KIND OF
RELIEF CAPACITY. IS THERE
FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET TO.
FORTIES INLAND PORTS ARE THESE
IN LAND FACILITIES TO KIND OF
RELIEVE SOME OF THE PORT
CONGESTION ON THESE EMPTY
CONTAINERS. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
BUT WE DO HAVE A TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS SUPPLY CHAIN
SLASH. RECALL LAW AND I'M GOING
TO ASK TREES THAT COVER TO
EXPLAIN SOME OF THE DECLINE IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION. HEY
GOOD AFTERNOON THREE TO COVER
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE TWO POINT THREE BILLION
ERICA EFER TO IS MADE UP OF THE
FOLLOWING COMPONENTS- AND WE CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON
THESE ALBUMS AND THERE'S
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THAT
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT
POSTED ON A WEBSITE. AND WE
ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
SPECIFIC OR PORT RELATED
PROJECTS THAT WOULD INCREASE
GOODS MOVEMENT CAPACITY WE HAVE
A RELATED- YOUR EMISSION
VEHICLE- IS GETTING YOUR MACHINE
PUT IN A NUMBER STRUCTURE FOR
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. NOT A WORKFORCE
TRAINING COMPONENT FOR A.
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE ALSO
HAVE UP FORTY NOT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES TO
HELP WITH THE STATE'S CAPACITY
ISSUE COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S
LICENSES ANOTHER COMPONENT WE
HAVE AS THIRTY MILLION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT RELATED
TO OPERATIONAL AND PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT COMPRISES
TWO POINT THREE BILLION THAT.
OKAY BUT IT IN THE LIST THERE IS
THERE'S NOTHING FOR DEVELOPING
LAND NEAR THE PORTS TO RELIEVE
THE CONGESTION FROM. AND ACCESS
INTO CONTAINERS WHICH WAS I
THINK WHAT WE DISCUSSED- IN
COMMITTEE THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION WOULD DECIDE
BY DECEMBER FIFTEENTH THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOME PATH THERE. I
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFICS ON AND
STATE ACCESS LAND BUT I'LL TAKE
THAT QUESTION- BACK FOR SURE.
BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
OTHER THAN YOU KNOW THE ONE
POINT TWO BILLION THAT I
REFERENCED AT THE TOP OF IT.
COULD BE YOURS FOR. RIGHT A
PORTRAIT OF POLITICS INCLUDING
RAILYARD EXPANSIONS A NEW
BRIDGES AND OTHER ZERO EMISSION
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT SPECIFICALLY
THAT THE STATE. LANDS REYES
OKAY. THANK YOU- AND JUMPING
ALMOST AS I KNOW WORSHIP SHORT
TIMES I WANT TO BE SENSITIVE
THAT LEADING MEMBERS AS
QUESTIONS IT HAS THE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED ANY MORE SPECIFICS ON
ON REFORMING CONSERVATORSHIP. IT
IS THERE. IS THERE MORE
SPECIFICS THERE. SO THEY GOT.
HAS DEFINITELY- BEEN PUBLIC
ABOUT HIS INTEREST IN DOING
SOMETHING LIKE CONSERVATIVE SHIP
WE DO NOT HAVE A PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME. WHEN WE DO HAVE A
PROPOSAL WE WILL BRING IT UP
BEFORE THIS GROUP FOR SESSION
OKAY AND HAVE HAVE YOU BROKEN
OUT THE NUMBERS WHERE WE KNOW
HOW MUCH IS BEING ALLOCATED FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT AND
MENTAL HEALTH. TREATMENT IS THAT
BROKEN OUT SOMEWHERE- I'LL TURN
THAT QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE
ADAM DORSEY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
THAT DETAIL AND WE DON'T WE CAN
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT.
EDITOR'S THE FINANCE SIDE- I
DON'T KNOW IF- THIS METRIC IS
HAS THAT NUMBER HANDY IF NOT
WE'LL WE'LL- CIRCLE BACK WITH
YOUR STAFF. GREAT IF YOU GET
THAT MAN I JUST TWO MORE
QUESTIONS- IN TERMS OF- A CO OF
IT I KNOW YOU JUST ANNOUNCED IT
YET OR THESE. ARE ASKING FOR
BILLION DOLLARS EXTRA- IS THERE
CAPACITY THERE I KNOW THAT WOULD
LEADING INTO THE BEGINNING OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR- THEY WERE
CHALLENGES WITH- THE WITH THE
GETTING THE TESTING ARE THE KIDS
TO THE SCHOOLS AND THEN OF
COURSE WE HAD CHALLENGES WITH
THE WITH THE FOURTH SURGE. ABOUT
TESTING FACILITIES AND ITS
ABILITY TO KIND OF ABSORB-
HIGHER THROUGHPUT- IS THAT WHY
THE AMOUNT IS GOING UP AT THE
BILLION DOLLARS OR CAN YOU KIND
OF SHED SOME LIGHT ON ON WHY IT
WENT FROM ONE POINT FOUR TO TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION. SURE I CAN
GIVE YOU- AN OVERALL SENSE AND
THEN I'M A ME THAT CALLING FOR
JUSTIN DETAILS BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHEN WE PUT THIS BUDGET
TOGETHER- THAT. PRIOR TO JANUARY
. WE WERE NOT REALLY IN THE
MIDST OF OR CRIME AND SO WE
REALLY WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IT'S
US TRYING TO BE VERY RESPONSIVE
TO THE MEDICAL HOSPITAL SURGEON
THE ADDITIONAL EXPANSION OF
TESTING- AS WELL AS- OUR OUR
PUSH FOR MORE VACCINES SO THAT'S
THE- THE REAL YOU KNOW. INCREASE
YOUR SEEING IS LARGELY TESTING-
FOR DTH ARM AS WELL AS SOME-
ADDITIONAL BUT FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE AS WE'VE
LEARNED THIS IS AN EVOLVING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
ATTEMPTING TO. HAVE IT- A
QUICKLY IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO
THAT'S THAT THE DIFFERENCE THAT
YOU'RE SEEING- IT'S ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED MILLION ADDITIONAL ON
TOP OF THE- STOKER AND MY LAST
QUESTION AND IT WILL BE- IN
REGARDS TO YOU- PAID SICK LEAVE
AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
HEARING ON THAT- COMING FORWARD
AS WE GET MORE SPECIFICS BUT HAS
THERE BEEN AN ANALYSIS DONE ON
SB NINETY FIVE. I MEAN PRE
EXTENSION AS WE DEBATE THE
EXTENSION- IT'S IMPACT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES THE IMPACT ON LABOR
MARKET I MEAN HAS THERE BEEN A
NOW SYSTEM WHERE YOU TO PROVIDE
US- THE COST TO SMALL BUSINESSES
IN. AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE
IT'S- IS IMPLEMENTATION. I'M I'M
NOT SURE THERE'S BEEN ANALYSIS
DONE ON ON THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU ASK I THINK. YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING- THE ABILITY FOR WORKERS
TO TAKE PAID SICK LEAVE AS- IS
EVIDENT- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN AN ANALYSIS ON THE
POTENTIAL COST TO BUSINESS- IT.
IN TERMS OF WEIGHING THE
BENEFITS OF NOT HAVING TO. COME
TO WORK VERSUS THE OUTPUT OF THE
WORKERS AT WORK SO I'LL TURN
THAT TO CHRIS CLICK TO SEE IF.
HE HAD ANY SPECIFIC ADDITIONS.
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO IT JUST AGAIN AS-
MISLI STATED NO ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS- ECONOMIC- DATA IS
AVAILABLE ON THAT. THAT WERE
AWARE. OKAY THE AND THE REASON
WHY I ASK IS THAT I THINK WHEN
WE ORIGINALLY DISCUSSED THE-
DISCUSS SB NINETY FIVE I THINK
THERE WAS A FEDERAL TAX CREDIT-
IN PLACE AND I THINK THAT HAS
EXPIRED. AND SO I'M I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- WHAT THE
COST WOULD BE- TO- TO SMALL
BUSINESSES INTO THE BUSINESS-
COMMITTEE IN GENERAL- AS WE
EVALUATE. AS EXTENSION SO- IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE US ANY
ANALYSIS I THINK THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND I THINK
THAT YOUR FIRST PATIENTS. THIRTY
WITH BRUSHED YOUR WE'RE GONNA GO
TO MR MATHESON AND MR SMITH.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR- I WANT
TO GO BACK TO THE DROUGHT
FUNDING QUICKLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE I HEARD THE PARMA FINANCE
CORRECTLY THAT THERE'S ZERO
MONEY FOR NEW STORAGE. YES
ALTERNATE AGAIN BACK TO CRYSTALS
HERE TO. YES THAT'S CORRECT
THERE'S NO FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR WATER STORAGE IN THE BUDGET
OKAY SO IS THERE ANYTHING FOR
ANY NEW WATER INTO THE STATE'S
SYSTEM. IF I'M UNDERSTANDING
YOUR QUESTION CORRECTLY- NOW
ALTHOUGH THE FUNDING THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE DROUGHT PACKAGE
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION- ARE
VERY S. WATER CONSERVATION- AT
PROJECTS AS THAT'S THE THING
ABOUT GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
URBAN AND SMALL COMMUNITY
DROUGHT RELIEF LEON REPURPOSE
SCENE- INSULATING. PERFORMERS SO
THERE'S NOT ANY THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM WE HAVE GOING INTO
ANOTHER DROUGHT IS THAT. THE
FUNCTION IN MY AREA IN THE
SILICON VALLEY DON'T HAVE WATER
THEY'RE HAVING TO CUT DEALS WITH
WITH OTHER AREAS TO MOVE WATER
TO DO THESE DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND WITHOUT ANY NEW WATER INTO
THE SYSTEM. THE CITIES ARE GONNA
GO DRY THIS IS A JUST- IN AG
ISSUE THIS IS THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE. DISADVANTAGE HI IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THAT AGAIN DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS. TO CLEAN RELIABLE
WATER. SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
THAT WE DO GET SOMETHING IN
THERE FOR MORE WATER INTO THE
SYSTEM- BECAUSE FRANKLY OUR
PEOPLE CAN'T DRINK DOLLARS SO
IT'S NICE TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO
PUT. MONEY IN INTO THE BUDGET
FOR DROUGHT BUT IF THAT MONEY
DOESN'T COME WITH WATER. IT IT
DOESN'T HELP SO WE NEED TO WORK
ON THAT THANK YOU. IT IF I COULD
JUST CLARIFY TEO- SO THERE THERE
IS IN TERMS OF. ADDING KIND OF
WATER AS STORAGE A MOTHER ISN'T
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING FOR ABOVE
GROUND WATER STORAGE- BEYOND
THAT THE EXISTING PROPOSITION
ONE FUNDING THERE IS FUNDING-
FOR AT SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT SO UNDERGROUND WATER
STORAGE- WHICH WHICH HAS.
CONSIDERABLY MORE CAPACITY THAN
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ABOVE
GROUND STORAGE SO- IN TERMS OF
THAT COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND
CONJUNCTIVE USE WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT AS A MORE. SUSTAINABLE
LONG TERM APPROACH TO WATER
AVAILABILITY- THERE IS THERE IS
FUNDING- FOR GROUNDWATER.
STORAGE CORRECT BUT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE WATER. TO GET. IN AND
YOU HAVE TO MOVE IT DOWN THE
CONVEYANCE SYSTEM AND THEN PUT
IT INTO THE GROUND WITHOUT ANY
MORE WATER. TO MOVE YOU STILL
HAVE NOTHING. OKAY ARE WE GONNA
MISS SMITH IN THE MISTER DAHLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY
QUESTION'S GOING TO BE IN
REGARDS TO INFRASTRUCTURE. ROLE
DISTRICTS LIKE MINDED THROUGHOUT
pTHE STATE WE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I THINK YOU
MENTIONED SOME FUNDING THERE.%
PUT UP MY DISTRICT IS HAVING A
HARD TIME GETTING MONEY FROM THE
HIGHWAY BRIDGE PROGRAM. AND HOW
MUCH IS IN THE BUDGET THAT
PROJECTED FOR PROJECTS THAT
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED HAVE A
PARTICULAR PROJECT THE BRIDGE IS
RATED THE NUMBER TWO SO IT'S
READY TO FALL DOWN. OUT OF THE
SKELETON. ALWAYS READY FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND NOW THEY GOT
CALLED LAST TUESDAY AND SAID
THERE'S NO FUNDING IN THE
HIGHWAY BRIDGE FUNDING. SO I'D
LIKE TO FIND OUT WHERE THAT
FUNDING MIGHT BE OR FOR HOW THE
PROJECT GOES. AND I'M NOT SURE
IF ERICA WILL ANSWER THAT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- SMITH I'M
GOING TO TURN THAT OVER TO YOU
TO RESET CALVERT FOR SOME
INFORMATION NEXT HOUSE UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DO NOT HAVE
THAT LEVEL OF INFORMATION SO AND
WILL REACH OUT TO YOUR OFFICE
STAFF TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL AND THEN WORK WITH.
CALTRANS TO SEE WHAT WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE AS A FOLLOW UP BUT
DON'T HAVE THAT ON HAND HERE-
THINKING WILL PROBABLY BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL TO BE
ABLE TO TRACK THAT DOWN OKAY.
NOW YOU CAN REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE WE GONNA REACH OUT TO YOU
WE GOTTA GET MAKE SURE WE GET
TOGETHER BECAUSE THIS PROJECT IS
FOR VERY CRITICAL FOR MY
DISTRICT. WE WILL. YEAH WE WILL
DEFINITELY REACH OUT TO YOUR
OFFICE. SO FIRST STREET BRIDGE
IN BARSTOW. SO THAT'LL GIVE YOU
SOME IDEA FOR THAT. OKAY THEN-
IN REGARDS TO EDUCATION HOW DOES
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOL EIGHTY A
CALCULATION AFFECT CHARTER
SCHOOLS. BECAUSE I KNOW CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN GETTING A LOT
OF EXPANSION BUT THERE'S NO
FUNDING ISSUES BEFORE CHARTER
SCHOOLS. I MISS MISS LEE DID YOU
HEAR THAT. ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT I
WAS ON MUTE. INTERNET OVER TO
CHRIS FERGUSON FOR MAKING.
MEMBER OUT CHRIS FERGUSON AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES NOT
DIRECTLY ADDRESS- CHARTER SCHOOL
DECLINING ENROLLMENT A WHAT WE
HAVE SIGNALED IN OUR BUDGET
SUMMARY IS THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH- CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
REPRESENTATIVES. TO UP FORMULATE
A POTENTIAL- THE POTENTIAL OF
THE SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AT CHARTER
SCHOOLS COME TO MAKE PROVISION.
YES THAT'S DECLINING AND IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS EXPANSION. IN
THE GROUP OF THE CALCULATION I
GOT PARTICULAR TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THAT THEY'VE HAD OVER
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS AND THEY NEED TO GET
THE FUNDING TO CARRY ON NOT GO
BACK TWO YEARS. WITHIN THE
NINETEEN PRE PANDEMIC THEY NEED
TO BE THE FUNDING RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE-
SURGICAL DRESSING SHUT DOWN
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE OPEN REAL
COMMUNITIES ARE OPEN. HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THE FUNDING FOR THESE
CHILDREN. SURE OF MOVING FORWARD
FROM TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. INTO
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING- THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
WOULD BE FUNDED AT CURRENT YEAR-
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE SO THAT
THOSE THAT ARE GROWING ARE BEING
FUNDED. YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL IN THIS BUDGET IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
CHANGE THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I'LL BE BRIEF BECAUSE
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS A
LOT OF THE CENTER SUBCOMMITTEES
BUT AS THAT YOU'RE BROUGHT UP IN
THE BLUEPRINT WHICH I KNOW HE
HAD A STRONG HAND AND THERE WAS-
THE ASSEMBLY BLUEPRINT BLUEPRINT
HAD A TEN BILLION FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND THAT'S A GREAT
WAY. TO INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM IS ESSENTIALLY OUT OF
MONEY- SO THAT THAT THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN AGAIN
USING SOME OF THOSE- ONE TIME
MONIES TO ADDRESS OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ACROSS THE
STATE IN OUR SCHOOLS WOULD BE A
VERY VALUABLE THING INVESTMENT
IN OUR FUTURE- AND I THINK THIS
IS. THIS IS SOMEWHAT LINKED TO-
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM US VERY-
COMMENTS- ALL ARTICULATED OVER
MANNER AND THAT IS THAT THE BASE
NEEDS TO BE MUCH HIGHER THE BASE
ALLOCATION LIMIT THE GOVERNOR
HAS FILE- HE'S PROPOSED A FIVE
POINT 33% DJUSTMENT THAT'S
UPWARD TO THE BASE ALLOCATION IT
NEEDS TO BE PROBABLY DOUBLE PLUS
THAT QUITE FRANKLY. DUE TO
INFLATION DUE TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND DUE TO STUDENT
NEEDS AND ALSO THIS IS NOT A
YEAR TO BE CREATING A LOT OF NEW
PROGRAMS. SCHOOLS NEED TO BE
OPEN THEIR STRESS TEACHERS ARE
STRESSING MINISTRY DISTRESS
STUDENT SUCCESS- IT'S NOT A YEAR
WHERE WE NEED TO DESIGN A BUNCH
OF PROGRAMS AT SCHOOLS YOU KNOW
SHOULD IMPLEMENT- BECAUSE AGAIN
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE KINDA WE'RE
STICKING TO THE BASICS SO WITH
THAT- YOU HEARD ME IT'S REALLY
ABOUT ADDING TO THE BASE SO THE
SCHOOLS CAN STAY AFLOAT. IN THE
OUT YEARS AS WELL THANK YOU. DID
YOU WANT TO COMMENT TO YOU JUST
TO MAKE A STEP. IT WAS MY
EDITORIAL STRUCTURE OKAY THANK
YOU MR. WE'RE GONNA GO WITH MR
COOPER DR RAINBOW WITH THE
DOCTOR. THANK YOU MISTER CHURCH
TO FOLLOW UP ON MISTER FALLS
QUESTION EARLIER SEWER. THREE
BILLION TOWARDS YOU I THIS YEAR
TWO BILLION NEXT YEAR. SO WHAT
STATE SEN WHAT STEPS ITS STATE
TAKING RECOVER THE CASH AND
ASSETS ATTAINED. WITH FRAUDULENT
EDIE CLAIMS. CHRIS COOK. THANKS
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO- AS AS USUAL WITH ANY
OVERPAYMENTS THAT- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. IS ONCE
THOSE OVERPAYMENTS ARE
IDENTIFIED THEY'RE MAKING- BEST
CONSERVATIVE EFFORTS TO RECOVER
THOSE FUNDS SO AS TO THE
SPECIFICS I DON'T KNOW- WHAT WAS
AREBUT I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ONCE THEY ARE IDENTIFIED THEY
ARE MAKING EFFORTS TO RECOVER
THOSE OVERPAYMENTS SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT TALKING OVER
PAYMENTS WERE TALKING ACTUAL
THEFT SO I MEAN SOME FOLKS
OVERPAID BUT- I'M- DOING DOWN ON
THE ON THE FIFTH PIECE. YES TO
OVERPAYMENTS WOULD INCLUDE THAT
WOULD INCLUDE FRAUD- OR- IF
FRAUDULENT- PAYMENTS AS WELL
BUT- ET DE IS MAKING THEIR BEST
CONCERTED EFFORTS TO RECOVER
THOSE FUNDS FOR FUN AS WELL YES.
IF ANYTHING THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DO TO HELP OUR CYSTIDIA
RECOVERING THESE FUNDS. YES SO
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET THEREARE
SEVERAL- I REQUEST FOR CONTRACT
FUNDS- TO ASSIST EDT IN THESE
EFFORTS AND- NOT ONLY- FOR
FRAUD- BUT NOT PREVENTING FUTURE
FRAUD. SO THERE IS SOME
PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET THAT
WOULD HELP EDT TO ASK FURTHER
ACCOMPLISH THEIR GOALS OF THOSE
OVERPAYMENTS. THANK YOU I
REQUEST NOT CANNABIS NOW FOR THE
A SIX MILLION PROPOSED FOR
CONSUMERS CONSUMER AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN. CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT
THAT INCLUDES. YES I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THAT RESPONSE. HI THIS IS
CAN BE HARVESTED FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AND THE CONSUMER
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN WOULD BE SIX
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS- IT'S
ON THE MULTI YEAR CONSUMER
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS. I KEEP TELLING OF THE
FRAMEWORK IS CONSUMER SAFETY AND
AWARENESS OF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW. THAT THE
PRODUCT THEY'RE BUYING IS SAFE
WHETHER THEY'RE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT OR A VISITOR FROM OUT
OF STATE. PHOTO BY BATTERY LEGAL
WEED THEN IS THAT WHAT IT IS.
THAT'S PART OF IT CORRECT. SO I
GUESS THE HARD PART IS IT'S
TOUGH BECAUSE I MEAN PEOPLE ARE
BUYING THE BLACK MARKETS DRIVING
BECAUSE IT'S CHEAPER THERE AND
OBVIOUSLY IT'S UNREGULATED SO I
DON'T KNOW. IF IT'S SHOWING HOW
THEY'RE GONNA BE NO SPLIT THAT
IT'S REALLY TOUGH I MEAN IT'S-
GOOD LUCK ON THAT- OKAY. THAT
NUMBER QUESTION ON THE ON THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT ISSUE-
FOR THE- TWENTY MILLION TO
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS. SO IT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SMALL BUSINESS
WITH THE MOST THE SMSH AND
GRABS. IT INVOLVED- HIGH END
RETAILERS OR LARGE BIG BOX
RETAILERS. HOW THIS TWENTY
MILLION- HOW CAN BE SURE THAT IT
GETS DOWN TO ACTUAL SMALL
BUSINESSES. IN IN THIS NAME IS A
SMALL BUSINESSES SO. HOW
REASSURED SMALL BUSINESSES THE
MONEY AND NOT CORPORATIONS. YEAH
THE DETAILS ABOUT GRANTS ARE
BEING WORKED OUT BUT I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MELBOURNE TO SEE IF
HE HAS ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD. HI
GOOD ATERNOON AND WEBER KARMA
FINDS. AND THEY'RE CONSIDERED TO
BE WORKED OUT THE DETAILS I
DON'T THINK ALWAYS TRYING TO
WORK IN DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
AND SPEAKING OF RETAILERS. WELL
THE BEST WAY TO. MANAGE THE
PROGRAM. AND I THINK THAT ONE
POSSIBILITY SPOKE ABOUT IS
HAVING A VETERAN ON THE BUSINESS
SO THE SMALL BUSINESS GRANT
PROGRAM HAD A CAPITALIST THIS BE
WITH. WITH AT HEALTH ISSUE. OKAY
NOT ONE APPLY THE GOVERNOR FOR
THE FOR THE NINETY FIVE MILLION
FOR A MONEY GOING TO LOCAL
GRANTS AND LOCAL OFFICES. AND
YOU KNOW CHP I IN A GOOD JOB.
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BIG ISSUES IS THAT- THE STATE
HAS FIVE TASK FORCES RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE SET UP IN THE NINETIES.
TO DO WITH IDENTITY THEFT RETAIL
CREDIT FRAUD. AND THE THINGS
THAT THE- ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
REALLY DRILL DOWN INTO. SO YOU
HAVE THESE TASK FORCES HAVE BEEN
IN EFFECT FOR TWENTY YEARS. AND
THEY ARE REALLY GETTING THAT
MUCH THE IN THERE PERFECTLY THE
PERMITTED BILL WITH THIS
OBVIOUSLY BEEN DOING IT FOR A
LONG TIME. IF THE EXPERIENCE
BUT- THE ISSUE IS GETTING THE
MONEY DOWN TO THEM. IN A SPEECH
PLEASE BEEN DOING A GREAT JOB AT
SEIZE P. IS NOT A THOUSAND
POSITION STATEWIDE. WE TOOK HER
POSITIONS HERE TO MAKE
TRAFFICKER THE CAPITAL. THERE
DOWN NINE HUNDRED ALREADY. IN
PREVIOUS YEARS ARE NOW SIX
CENTERS WITH EACH B. CONTINUES
TO- LOSE POSITIONS. IN THE
MEANTIME WE ARE COUNTIES ARE
SCREAMING BECAUSE THERE'S NO
TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT. IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS- SO. SO HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH THAT IN. YOU
KNOW HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
MONEY GETS TO THE RIGHT FOLKS
THAT THAT REALLY HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN THIS. YEAH I THINK
THE STATE IS GOING TO TAKE A- A
COLLABORATIVE ROLE WITH LOCALS.
IN REGARDS TO THAT AND I DON'T
KNOW IF- THERE'S MORE DETAIL
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR BUT AT
THAT POINT THAT'S- I'LL ALSO
BEING. WORKED OUT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IS FOR. THE EXPANSION OF
THIS TASK TWELVE AND THE H. P.
OUR SUPPORT. IN JUST LET MY LAST
QUESTION- IS THERE ANY FUNDING
RIGHT NOW FOR THE I KEPT US
FORCES IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET- I
ALTERNATE QUESTION TO- ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES. AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
A RESPONSE I CAN GET BACK TO YOU
. OKAY I WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU- MISTER COOPER OKAY. OF THE
PROJECT. DR MARK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FROM HI I WILL
BEGIN WITH SOME FRAMING COMMENTS
AND SAVE MY QUESTIONS FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS BUT I
WANTED TO BEGIN WITH AN
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP DURING THIS
PANDEMIC OF THE CENTURY WE HAVE
BEEN WEATHERING THIS STORM
TOGETHER WHETHER OR NOT WE ALL
CAME FROM THE SAME SHIPS
ORIGINALLY WE ARE ALL NOW ON
THIS BOAT CALLED CALIFORNIA. AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE VISION THAT HE'S HAD FOR
A STATE HIS ABILITY TO FOLLOW
SCIENCE AND PROVIDE A DIRECTION
FOR OUR STATE IS REFLECTED WITH
IN THIS BUDGET AND WANTED TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE VALUES THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET PROPOSED
ON JANUARY TENTH. BUT THIS
PROJECT WILL CONTINUE THE LEGACY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN LEADING
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
ALL WHO CALLED THE STATE HOME
AND ARE INCOME ELIGIBLE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND WE HAVE THE HARD WORK OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS POLICY OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND THEN
ROLLING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
CALLED THE CENTRAL AND NEED TO
HAVE THEIR ESSENTIAL NEEDS TAKEN
CARE OF COURT TO THAT. BEING
HEALTHCARE. BUT AS WE CONTINUE
TO ADVANCE AND IMPROVE AND
ENROLL PEOPLE INTO MEDIC HAL WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING A GOOD QUALITY AS
WELL. AND THAT'S WHY I'M EXCITED
TO WORK WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION
ON THE CAL AIM PROPOSAL THAT IS
BOTH TRANSFORMATIVE AND
FOUNDATIONAL TO CHANGING THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS AND-
CARE THAT WE PROVIDE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THE CHANGES THAT
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT TO IMPROVE
BOTH HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN THE
SYSTEMS OF CARE DELIVERY ALSO
LEAD US TOWARDS CONVERSATION AND
ENSURING THAT WE PROVIDE
AFFORDABILITY WITHIN HEALTHCARE.
AND BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR OUR SUB COMMITTEE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PUTTING QUALITY METRICS IN
PLACE. AS WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT COST WE
CANNOT LOSE. SIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT IT IS PEOPLE WHO ARE WE ARE
CARING FOR AND MUST ESTABLISH.
METRICS THAT WE CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO. WE ALL KNOW THAT
THAT WHICH IS NOT MEASURED
CANNOT BE IMPROVED AND WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CONTROLLING COSTS THAT WE ARE
SIMILARLY LOOKING T THE QUALITY
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS THERE AS
WELL. BUT I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THE METRIC SAYS I BELIEVE THAT
IS A KEY PART THAT MY OFFICE
WILL WORK ON FOR THE ORDERS THAT
ARE IN STATUTES NOW BOTH IN
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES. AND THEN
CAL WORKS OR IS AN ACRONYM FOR
THE OUTCOME AND ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW. AND IT'S A PROCESS TO
HELP TO IMPROVE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND TO ESTABLISH
METRICS THAT WE CAN LATER BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO. I INTEND
FOR US AS THE LEGISLATURE TO DO
ITS DUE DILIGENCE AND OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AS WE
IMPLEMENT MANY OF THE GREAT
PROPOSALS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ULTIMATELY GET A GOOD RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS AN
INSTITUTION IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROVIDE THAT NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT AND I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT WORK AS THE
CHAIR OF SOMEONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU DR WORKED AND
THEY WERE GOING TO GO TO MR
BENNETT AND MR MCCARTY. YEAH AND
IT'S JUST JUST A JUST A SIMPLE
QUESTION AND- WHEN WILL WE EIGHT
OF WHEN CAN WE EXPECT TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE ON THE COVE IT PAID
LEAVE. PROPOSAL I'M SURPRISED
WE'RE GETTING OUT A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF PHONE CALLS IN OUR
OFFICE ABOUT ABOUT THAT AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ANSWER CONSTITUENTS SO WHEN
CAN WE EXPECT THAT LANGUAGE. YES
MISTER WHERE WE CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THAT AND- I BELIEVE WE
WILL HAVE THAT LANGUAGE- SOON
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE THE DATE
BUT I'M I'LL TURN THAT QUESTION
TO. CHRIS COOK FOR SOME DETAILS
. YES AS A MISLI INDICATED THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS CONTINUING
TO REFINE THAT LANGUAGE AND WILL
WE SHOULD BE- SHARING THAT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING
DAYS. THANK YOU. I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA GO TO MISTER BENNETT THE
MISTER MCCARTY THE MISTER ABBAS
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR- MY A FIRST
QUESTION DEALS WITH THE NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT DOES IN THE BUDGET
FOR- THOUSAND ZERO MISSION SHORT
HAUL TRUCKS IN SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
EUROVISION TRANSIT BUSES. AND I
APPRECIATE A QUESTION IT WAS
EARLIER IN TERMS OF LOCATION BUT
IT IS THERE ANY PLANNING AT THIS
POINT TIME ON THE PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR THOUGHTS IN
TERMS OF HOW YOU LOGICALLY
LOCATE THESE- SO THEY MAKE
SENSE- I THINK SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE PARTICULAR TALK
ABOUT COMMERCIAL VEHICLES AND
WHEN WE GO TO THE HEAVIER DUTY
COMMERCIAL VEHICLES. IT MAY MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE TO HAVE THE SINKS
LOCATED IN A WAY THAT THERE IS A
CUSTOM CONFIDENCE THAT YOU KNOW
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO IF YOU MAKE
THE INVESTMENT IN THE VEHICLE
THAT ON THE ROUTE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE GOING THERE WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO REFUELING
STATIONS. A COULD ANYBODY HELP
ME WITH THAT PLACE. SURE I'LL
JUST START WITH- SORT OF A BROAD
OVERVIEW AND THEN TURN IT OVER
TO SERGIO AGUILAR BUT THE
INVESTMENTS ARE BOTH FOR YOUR
CALLS AND TRUCK REPLACEMENT AS
WELL AS CHARGING STATIONS THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
WE'RE THINKING- IS STATEWIDE BUT
IT THAT'S IT AS REGARDS TO
REGION'S I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
SERGIO AGUILAR. THANK YOU. YET
EVEN THOUGH THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS- YOU KNOW THE WHAT OF THE BIG
FACTORS WITHIN OUR ENTIRE THAT
PROPOSAL IS LOOKING AT EQUITY IN
LOOKING AT THOSE AREAS THAT ARE
MOST HABITAT BANDAGE AND HAVE
THE- AIR QUALITY AIR POLLUTION
IMPACT. SO THAT IT KIND OF ONE
OF THE KEYBOARD THE FRAMEWORK
THAT HELPS DETERMINE- SOME OF
THAT- BUT WE- THE AIRPORT AND
ALTHOUGH THE ENERGY COMMISSION
THAT IS PART OF THAT THE FUNDING
BUT- WITH THE ACTUAL VEHICLE BE
AIRPORT BOTH REPUBLIC PROFIT I
THINK WE EVERY YEAR- TAX
TREATMENT SOME OF THE CRITERIA.
OF THE GUIDELINES AND SO THAT
THAT ALLOWS- BROUGHT IN BY. THE
COMMUNITY YEAH I'LL BEAT HELP ON
THE CRITERIA AND ALL THAT-
HOLDEN WE AWARDED AND IF YOU'RE
GEOGRAPHICALLY THOUGH I DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER AT THE BIG
DETAILS ON OUR GEOGRAPHY BUT-
THEY DO HAVE A PRETTY OPEN
PUBLIC. PROCESS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH THE BOARD OPTED OUT
RIGHT HERE PART OF THE PROGRAM.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND OVERALL I
BUT I CERTAINLY DO WANT TO
COMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM-
THE COMMITMENT TO TRY TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
CLIMATE CHANGES IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND EVIDENT HERE. I
WOULD POINT OUT- I ONLY RAISED
THE QUESTION OF- I'D THE
COMMITMENT TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- FROM AN EQUITY
STANDPOINT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TERMS OF LOCATION OF APPROVING
AIR QUALITY. BUT TO IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY WE HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
MAKE THE INVESTMENTS IN THE
VEHICLES I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE PEOPLE MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS OF THE VEHICLES FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT. WHEREVER THEY
THAT THEY THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY. ECONOMICALLY OPERATE
THE VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY'LL BE A FUELING STATION
EVEN IF THAT'S MAY HAVE TO BE
LOCATED OUTSIDE OF A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. MY
SECOND QUESTION- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- COMMITMENT OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF GREEN HYDROGEN- TO
USE ELECTRICITY SPLIT WATER
DOCTOR CHEN. AND MY- MY-
QUESTION IS THAT. WE HAVE A CAL
WHERE TO ENOUGH SOLAR FOR OUR
AND WINTER TIME MEANS HAVE X.
SOLAR ENERGY IN THE SUMMERTIME-
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT- THE SUN IS SHINING AND THE
ANGLE THAT IS THERE HAS THERE
BEEN ANY THOUGHT GIVEN TO
FINDINGWAYS TO INCENTIVIZE IN
PARTICULAR THE EXCESS SOLAR
ENERGY THAT WE HAVE IN THE
SUMMERTIME- AND USING THAT TO
PRODUCE THE SCREEN HYDROGEN. YES
QUESTION APPROACH TO BASIC
HEALTHCARE. OUR WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I DON'T KNOW BUT WE
WILL TAKE THAT THAT COMMENT BACK
BUT- I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC- OF LINKAGE TO THAT TO
THAT SUMMER USAGE TO THE GREEN
HYDROGEN PROPOSAL THAT WE WILL
TAKE THAT COMING BACK THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I HAVE JUST
A COUPLE COUPLE OF JUST VERY
QUICK POINTS NUMBER ONE I
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING- THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKERS TO
SUBSIDIZE OUR LEARNING AND JOB
TRAINING AS WE MAKE THIS SWITCH
IS ONE THAT WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
AND I JUST WANTED TO- EQUITY IT
MIGHT MY APPRECIATION FOR THAT
BEING RECOGNIZED IN THE BUDGET-
YOU WE ALSO HAVE IN THE BUDGET A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
DEVELOP GREEN- GREEN. ENERGY OF
RIVER RIGHT IF SOURCES AND I
JUST WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF. UP FOR.
THE INNOVATIVE ASPECT OF THAT
WHICH IS THAT IF THE COMPANY
BECOMES PROFITABLE CALIFORNIA
GETS A SHARE OF THE PROFITS- I
THINK THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT MAKES A TAXPAYERS FEEL
BETTER- AND SOMETHING THAT. I
THINK WE SHOULD TRY TO APPLY AS
OFTEN AS WE CAN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND THE FINAL QUESTION
. DEALS WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ASKING YOU. SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT WATER NEW WATER
SOURCES X. SENTARA- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THE BUDGET
WATER RECYCLING COMMUNITIES THAT
WANT TO START TO. RECYCLE MORE
OF THEIR WATER INSTEAD OF SIMPLY
DISCHARGING IT INTO THEIR INTO
THE WASTE TREATMENT CENTER- THAT
DOES RECYCLING PROJECTS WOULD
BE- PART OF THE- OF FOR COULD BE
FUNDED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RIGHT NOW COULD SOMEBODY
CONFIRM THAT BECAUSE THAT.
CERTAINLY COULD BE VIEWED AS NEW
WATER BECAUSE IT'S WATER THAT
YOU KNEW WHAT WE WERE USING. AT
ALTERNATE OVER TO CRYSTALS HERE
TO. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK
YOU- FOR THAT FOR THAT QUESTION
WE CERTAINLY VIEW I WATER
RECYCLING AND CONSERVATION A
WATER CONSERVATION PROGRAMS EVEN
MORE BROADLY- S. PROGRAMS THAT
CONTRIBUTE GEO I'M A HIGHER FLAT
SUPPLY OF WATER- TO YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT WATER
RECYCLING AND YES THERE IS A
SPECIFIC FUNDING ARE INCLUDED IN
THE WATER RESILIENCE PACKAGE-
FROM FROM LAST YEAR WHICH WAS A
THREE YEAR PACKAGE- IT'S FUNDING
FOR BOTH WATER RECYCLING AND
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP-
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
BUDGET YOUR THERE'S A- HUNDRED
MILLION AND THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
HUNDRED MILLION- NEXT YEAR FOR A
TOTAL. FOUR HUNDRED MILLION A
LOT OF RESPECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY BENEFIT FROM
BEING ABLE TO IDENTIFY THAT AS
NEW WATER SOURCES FOR CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MISS MCCARTY
THAN MISTER RAMOS SYNONYMOUS
FIGHTERS. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT FIRST TO MISTER BENNETT
JUST TOOK ANOTHER ONE TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
ABOUT GREEN HYDROGEN I'VE NO
IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUT I'M SURE HE'LL EXPLAIN IT TO
ME LET ME FASCINATING. BOB BUT
BIG PICTURE I WANTED TO JUST TAG
ONTO WHAT ARE CARE SAID AT THE
OUTSET THIS IS A GREAT BUDGET-
BUILDING FRANKLY OFF LAST YEAR'S
WORK WE DID SOME AMAZING
TRANSFORMATIONAL ACTIONS LAST
YEAR ON PUBLIC EDUCATION EARLY
AT HEALTHCARE- HIGHER READ OF
COURSE MOST IMPORTANTLY MAKING
THE BUDGET FISCALLY SOUND AND
SAVING FOR THE RAINY DAY. SO
WHILE THERE'S NOT A LOT OF NEW
THINGS IN THIS BUDGET A LOT OF
WHAT IT DOES IS FUNDS AND
IMPLEMENT WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON
LAST YEAR BUT JUST WANTED. TO
FOCUS ON THE THREE HIGHER AT K.
TWELVE AND EARLY AT ISSUES- WILL
WILL BE IN SEPT TWO AND WE'LL
GET TO IN GREATER DETAIL SO
WANTED TO- THAT KNOWLEDGE AND
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
STARTING THE FUNDING FOR THE
CHILD CARE EXPANSION AND
UNIVERSAL T. K. WHICH WILL BE A
BIG BOOM FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND ALSO WORKING
FAMILIES BUT WE ARE HEARING FROM
FROM POPLE WHO ARE IN THE WORK
FORCE THAT. WE HAVE A CHALLENGE
ON A PEOPLE TO WORK IN THESE
PROFESSIONS- SEE MAKE SURE THAT
WE FOCUS ON- FINISHING AND
FINALIZING THE RATE REFORM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PAY- THESE
PROVIDERS ADEQUATE- REIMBURSE.
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
FINANCIALLY. AND PAY THEIR
WORKERS A LIVING WAGES- WE ARE
TIME AND TIME AGAIN ABOUT PEOPLE
CAN LEAVE AND GO TO WORK. MAKE
MORE MONEY- MAKING A PERFECT
STARBUCKS LATTE BUT UPPING MAKE
A PERFECT THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS WE TO FOCUSED ON OUR
PRIORITIES- AS FAR AS OUR OUR K.
TWELVE. SCHOOLS YOU KNOW OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND EDUCATORS
ARE THE MVPS IN COVERAGE TRYING
TO GETTING. OUR STUDENTS BACK.
TO LEARNING AND HELPING FAMILIES
GET BACK TO WORK- WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR TEACHER AN EDUCATOR
SHORTAGE SO. I WOULD LIKE TO
PROPOSALS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET I WILL BE FINE TUNING
THEM A POTENTIALLY ADDING SOME
MORE- IN THE- IN THE IN THE
PROCESS- AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THE PAST UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS- WE'RE- FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THAT- I THINK WE-
NEED TO FINE TUNE- SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS TO MAKE SURE THEY
CAN HELP ALL. FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE. A FREE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS WE PROMISED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET- IN THAT
HIGHER READ BRIEFLY I JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT- AS MR O'DONNELL
SAID I FULLY SUPPORT LOOKING AT
ONE TIME MONEY. FOR SCHOOL
FACILITIES ALSO A PROPER USE OF
ONE TIME MONEY IN THE HIGHER ED.
IS AND HOUSING WHICH WE DID LAST
YEAR FOR TWO BILLION. AND WE'VE
WE'VE HAD SUCH A SURGE IN THE
AMOUNT OF CAMPUS IS APPLYING FOR
THIS MONEY. IT SHOWS THE- IT
SHOWS THE- THE DEMAND. SO
POTENTIALLY WE COULD PUT SOME
MORE IN THE CURRENT YEAR. FOR
HOUSING WHICH WOULD HELP- A
CURRENT. STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING
TO PAY ITS MEAT FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE- ALLOW CMPUS IS TO GROW IN
ACCOMMODATE. CAL AND ALL ADDRESS
THE HOUSE SHORTAGE AS AS A WHOLE
- SO JUST SOME SOME ISSUES OUT
OF THE GATES WERE MAKE. AWARE
THAT WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THROUGH
THE- BUDGET COMMITS BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO MISTER
RAMOS. AND THE METS FIGHTERS.
AND THEN MISS GARCIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER- I HAVE A
COMMENTED. QUESTIONS AND FIRST
IN REGARDS TO THE- ONE TIME-
PROP NINETY EIGHT ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO BUILD- CURRICULUM THE
GOVERNOR'S PUT IN THERE. IN
PARTICULARLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN EDUCATION-
MAKING SURE THE CURRICULUM IS-
FACTUALLY PORTRAYED. IN THE
STATE I WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR. PUTTING THAT IN
THERE AND ALSO TESTING TO IS A-
HAS A HAS PROMISED TO THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE TO GET FACTUAL
HISTORY. MOVING FORWARD AND MANY
KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD. ON THAT ASPECT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK HARD AND
PARTNERING WITH THE GOVERNOR TO
MOVE THOSE AREAS FORWARD. THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS ON THE-
RETAIL THEFT IN THE IN THE MONEY
THAT'S BEING- PUT IN THERE AS
FAR AS PUBLIC SAFETY. AND THE
QUESTION IS THERE ANY- AND-
HINDRANCE TO USING- TECHNOLOGY
COMPONENTS FOR SOME OF THAT
FUNDING THAT THAT. COULD BE
OFFERED TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
YEAH I'M NOT SURE THERE'S ANY
LIMITATIONS OR RESTRICTIONS ON
THAT- USAGE OF THE FUNDING I'LL
TURN THAT QUESTION TO JUSTIN IT
AMEND IT TO CONFIRM NOT. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUST NAY NEWMAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RIGHT NOW
WE DON'T HAVE ANY STIPULATIONS
ABOUT YOU NO EXCLUSIONS FOR WHAT
THE EIGHTY DAY. NINETY FIVE
MILLION ANNUALLY- FOR VARIOUS
GRANTS. BE PUT TOWARDS- SO
THERE'S NO EXCLUSION RIGHT NOW
ON WHAT CAN BE USED FOR. THANK
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THE
REASON I BRING THAT UP IS
BECAUSE THEY USE THE TECHNOLOGY-
WHAT WITH. ONE HIGHER- OFFICERS
AND DEPUTIES IS ONE THING BUT
UTILIZING ONE TIME MONEY FOR
TECHNOLOGY- IN PARTICULAR MAYBE
SOME OTHER AREAS SUCH AS GPS
TRACKERS THAT COULD- FOLLOW SOME
OF THOSE RETAIL THEFTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE
APPREHENDED. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE THERE SO I WANT TO PUT
THAT IN- TE DISCUSSION BECAUSE
A LOT OF TIMES WHEN PEOPLE SEE
THE MONEY AND FUNDING GOING
TOWARDS LAW ENFORCEMENT IT
EQUATES TO- NEW DEPUTIES ARE NEW
OFFICERS ON THE STREET BUT OF
ITS ONE TIME FUNDING. IT COULD
BUT IT PUTS SOME OF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN A BIND FOR
FUTURE FUNDING TO KEEP THOSE-
MEMBERS- WITHIN THE FOREST BT
ONE TIME MONEY GOING TOWARDS
TECHNOLOGY. IS AN AREA THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO EXPLORE AND TO-
COME UP WITH SOME DIFFERENT
IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN ACTUALLY
CREATE- A PULL- THAT WE COULD
PULL MONEY AND GRANTS FOR
TECHNOLOGY USE WERE BATTLING.
AREAS SUCH AS RETAIL THEFT. I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH- WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT. MY
NEXT QUESTION GOES BACK TO- SOME
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENTS-
CERTAINLY COVER NINETEEN HAS A-
HAVE AN EFFECT. ON ALL OF US BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION THAT HAS A-
HAD A DRASTIC EFFECT SO WE WANT
TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SPEAKING UP ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT THERE. BUT ALSO-
BRINGING. TO THAT TO THE FRONT
INTO THE FALL THE HOMELESS
STUDENTS- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY CONTINUED TO.
LOOK FOR RESOURCES WITHIN MENTAL
HEALTH. AND I KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR WORKED ON THAT LAST-
BUDGET CYCLE BUT WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN IT COMES TO- SUB
ONE THAT THOSE ARE COMPONENTS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKING
ABOUT. AS FAR AS MENTAL HEALTH
FOR OUR HOMELESS YOUTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH IN GENERAL- FOR
OUR POPULATIONS SITE. JUST
WANTED TO- LAY THAT SEAT OR EVEN
ASK THE QUESTION. IS THE
HOMELESS- YOUTH POPULATION
ENGAGE- WITHIN- THE BUDGET-
PROPOSAL. WITH ANY SPECIFIC
RESOURCES- FOR. THAT SUB
POPULATION IN GENERAL. SURE
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION MR
ALMOST I WANT TO JUST POINT BACK
TO LAST YEAR'S- INVESTMENT IN
THAT. BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
USE- THAT IT SO IT STARTED LAST
YEAR WAS A MULTI YEAR-
ENDEAVORED TO REALLY TRANSFORM
BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOR OUR USE IN
SCHOOLS AND OUTSIDE SCHOOLS- SO
THERE'S BEST MEN'S AND- THAT
THIS CURRENT YEAR AS WELL- BUT
FOR FURTHER DETAILS I WILL. SEND
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE-
RECORDED WITHIN OUR CAST. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION ONE
ELEMENTARY GUESS WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO SOME OF
THE PROPOSALS AND THIS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE FOR THE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN GENERAL I
WILL FOLLOW UP. WILL FOLLOW BACK
WITH YOU- I'M MORE SPECIFICS-
RELATED TO YOUR QUESTION ON-
HOMELESS STUDENTS. THANK YOU AND
THEN- I GUESS WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH THAT DURING SOME WONDERING-
REACH OUT TO MY OFFICE ON. WITH
THAT RESPONSE. WELL RICHARD TO-
BUDGET STAFF AND FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY TO- COMMUNICATE WITH
OFFICE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MISS MY DEAREST
MISS GARCIA THAN MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AS MANY
AS TWENTY OTHER STATES INCLUDING
DELAWARE NEW HAMPSHIRE AND
HAWAII UTILIZE FEDERAL OR
SURPLUS MONEY TO PROVIDE RELIEF
TO THEIR YOU AYE FUNDS TO HELP
ADDRESS THE INSOLVENCY CAUSED BY
THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING A SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT
BY TEXAS CALIFORNIA PROPOSED
THREE BILLION IN REPAYMENT- AS A
STEP TO RELIEVING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FROM EXTENDED YEARS OF
RISING FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
TAXES. YET DOES NOT CLEAR THEM
COMPLETELY OF HIGHER TAXES IN
ADDITION TO THIS PARTIAL
REPAYMENT OF THE NINETEEN POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR DEBT WHICH
INCLUDES THAT OF ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DUE TO FRAUD THIS BODY
AND THE GOVERNOR NEED TO PROVIDE
LONG TERM ASSISTANCE AND
SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH THE TRUST
FUND INSOLVENCY. SO WE
ALLOCATED. A BILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR OR IN THE PROPOSAL
THERE'S AN ALLOCATION OF A
BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR AND
TWO BILLION DOLLARS NEXT YEAR.
IF WE CONTINUE TO PAY DOWN. TO
PAY THIS DEBT DOWN AT THIS RATE
. WHEN WOULD WE PAY THIS OFF
DOES DOES EITHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND OR THE L. A. L.
NOW. THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
IS SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW
MUCH TIME HE SHAVED OFF AND- AT
THE END BUT IT DOES HELP REDUCE
RATES- WHAT IT HELPS THE STATE
AS WELL AS EMPLOYERS. IN THE
LONG TERM. SO IT WAS A ROUGHLY
WEAKENED IF THE L. A. L. O.
WANTS TO WIN HERE I MEAN COULD
WE LOOK AT IF PAYING IT DOWN AT
THIS RATE OF YOU KNOW TWO
BILLION APPROXIMATELY A YEAR.
BUT IT TAKES ABOUT A DECADE.
YES- THIS IS GAVE PATRICK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND- ESCHEN
WITH THE AMOUNT BEING PROPOSED.
IF IT WERE CONTINUE TO. YOU KNOW
SIMILAR AMOUNTS WENT FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE I THINK WE'RE LOOKING
AT SOMETHING THAT THE TOWARD THE
END OF THE DECADE SEEKS. DEBT
WOULD BE PAID DOWN BUT UNDER THE
FEDERAL RULES AS YOU NOTED THE-
THE EMPLOYERS WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO AT YOU KNOW ZERO POINT 3% TAX
INCREASE ON THEIR PAYROLL TAXES
UNTIL THE TIME WHEN IT'S PAID
DOWN SO. IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE
INTERESTED IN PROVIDING MORE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF THERE MIGHT BE
OTHER OTHER ALTERNATIVE STATE
WOULD WANT TO CONSIDER- AS
OPPOSED TO THIS APPROACH. SO
LAST YEAR THEY ADMINISTER
MINISTRATION OF KNOWLEDGE THAT
WE WOULD HAVE TO PAY DOWN DEBT-
ON THE BACKS OF SMALL BUSINESS
UNLESS WE- INVESTED MORE IN PAIN
THIS DOWN ESPECIALLY WITH THESE
ONE TIME SURPLUS DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE. SO WHAT IF WE'RE ONLY
ALLOCATING GONNA ONE BILLION
THIS YEAR TWO BILLION NEXT YEAR.
WHEN WOULD YOU WANT ONE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATE THAT
BUSINESSES WOULD START TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN THEIR E. Y. PAYMENTS. YES SO AS- MISTER PEDICLE
SAYING THAT FOR EVERY YEAR THERE
IS A BALANCE. OR SOME DEBT
REMAINING IN A STATE THAT THE
EMPLOYERS THAT PAY INTO THE
TRUST FUND WOULD NOT SEE THAT
CREDIT. AND SO THEY WOULD FEEL-
INCREASED. COST OF STARTING NEXT
YEAR JANUARY. THANK YOU I. I
JUST LOOK AT THE OVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND BUSINESSES THAT WERE
PROBABLY CLOSE IN THE STATE. AND
pARE STILL STRUGGLING AND I JUST
HOPE THAT THAT WE CAN REALLY-
PROVIDE SOME RAL REPRIEVE FOR
THEM- AND ENSURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING THEM WHEN THEY NEED
IT MOST THEY'VE BEEN HERE FOR US
WHEN. WE NEED TO BE THERE FOR
THEM. MY NEXT QUESTION IS AROUND
AND- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADD THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
SLOTS ON TOP OF THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND THAT WERE
FUNDED IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET PACKAGE. I'M MOVING
TOWARD THE GOAL OF ADDING A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MORE SLOTS BY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX- AND I AM EXCITED ABOUT THIS
I HAVE SAID YOU KNOW- FROM THE
GET GO THAT WE CANNOT EXPECT TO
GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK IF THEY
DON'T HAVE CHILD COURT CARE- AND
I THINK THIS IS EIGHT EIGHT GOAL
HOWEVER IT'S REALLY UNCLEAR.
UNCLEAR WHETHER THESE SLOTS CAN
BE ACCESSED BY FAMILIES MOST
NEEDED IT WHAT THE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO TO THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR- YET OR
EVEN OUT OF THE ALLEY OWN YOU
MAY HAVE SOME INSIGHT HERE WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THE FIELD WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
INCREASES STIPEND ALLOCATIONS
AND THE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN- AND
BUT NEED TO ADD NEW SLOTS THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ADDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND DO WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE HOW MANY. SLOTS HAVE
BEEN FILLED. YES THAT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE ASKING FOR A STATUS
UPDATE ON- THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WERE MADE AST YEAR I'M NOT SURE
IF WE HAVE. THAT HANDY- I'LL SEE
IF NYBODY ON THE LINE AS A
FORMATION BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO
GET THAT RESPONSE. BACKS YOU IN
MORE DETAIL- MISTER DORSEY.
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT. THIS IS
TYLER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I CAN TAKE THAT PART OF
THAT QUESTION AT LEAST SO I KNOW
THAT- MOST OF THE STIPENDS HAVE
ALREADY GONE OUT THE DOOR- EVEN
AS RECENTLY AS ABOUT. GO WE CAN
PROVIDE YOUR OFFICE AN UPDATE
THE L. ON THE SLOT AVAILABILITY
AT THIS POINT I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE. A NUMBER OF BREAK OUT
RIGHT NOW ON EXACTLY HOW MANY OF
THOSE SLOTS ARE ACTIVE. I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT FOLLOW UP. I'M
I'M HEARING FROM THE FIELDS YOU
KNOW WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY
CHILD CARE FACILITIES I'VE
CLOSED. I'M WOULD DOES THE ONLY-
HAVE ANY INSIGHT AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT. YOU KNOW THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY FIELD AND CAN ACTUALLY
ACCOMMODATE THE THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND. NEW SLOTS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I DON'T
SEE ANY ALLOCATION FOR THE WORK
FORCE FOR CHILD CARE. AND INTO
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CONCERNS IS
THAT WERE WERE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS AND IT'S REALLY
HARD TO RECRUIT. SO WHY WOULDN'T
WE- PUT MONIES TOWARDS
RECRUITMENT AND WORKFORCE. WELL
I WILL I'LL- GET THAT QUESTION
TO TYLER WHAT'S- SURE SO I
THINK- TO PARTIALLY ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION I THINK THAT'S PART OF
THE ONGOING DISCUSSION ABOUT
RATE REFORMS THAT HOPEFULLY. AS
RATES GET DEVELOPED IN A BETTER
MORE SINGULAR WAY IN ADDITION TO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BUT THAT
MIGHT BECOME MORE APPEALING AND
HELP WITH SOME OF THE FIELD. AND
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS BUT I JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT THERE WAS
FUNDING APPROPRIATE IN TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT FOR THINGS LIKE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR FACILITY
FACILITIES AND REHABILITATION.
AS WELL AS THINGS LIKE THE
STIPENDS AND SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING IN THE TWENTY ONE ACT IT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE INCENTIVE TO
KEEP WORKERS CONTINUING TO WORK
AS WELL AS A RECRUITMENT EFFORT
. THIS IS CHRIS FERGUSON IF I
COULD ADD A AND- WITHIN THE
COMPACT THAT WE PUT FORWARD FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY ONE
OF THE AREAS OF FOCUS. IS
INCREASING ENROLLMENT AND
GRADUATION RATES UP WITHIN A
CERTAIN AREAS I'M ONE OF THE
AREAS OF FOCUS IS A PUBLICATION
INCLUDING EARLY EDUCATION. OR OR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS SO
WE'RE CERTAINLY FOCUSED ON THAT
AREA IN OUR COMPACTS- AS WELL AS
THE ROAD MAP FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ADDITIONALLY
ONE OF THE AREAS OF FOCUS ON THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER PATHWAYS. IN OUR K.
TWELVE SPACE ALSO FOCUSES ON
EDUCATORS AND EARLY EDUCATION OR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION-
EDUCATORS AS WELL. THANK YOU ACT
INCLUDE- LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION AROUND WORK FORCES
SPECIFICALLY RUN EARLY CHILD
CARE- NO FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. I THINK YOU'RE GONNA GONNA
MISS GARCIA THE MISTER GALLAGHER
AND THEN MISTER LEE- THANK YOU-
I GUESS IS MORE COMMON THAN A
QUESTION AND WILL BE. COVERING A
LOT OF THIS AND BUDGET THE FIVE
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT MR ALMOST
BROUGHT UP THE MONEY PROPOSED OF
TO ADDRESS ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT- AND SO I DO HAVE THAT
COMMON GOAL I DO HOPE WE'LL
START TO SEE SOME VERY DETAIL
CENTURY AT THAT MONIES YOU SEEN
BEING USED. WISELY BUT ALSO
BEING USED FOR THE TENTH
INTENDED PURPOSES OUT THERE AS
OF PROPOSALS MOVE FORWARD AND I
WOULD SAY THAT'S JUST IN GENERAL
WE SAW A LOT OF PROPOSALS AND
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY FOR US TO
WORK WITH AND THAT'S EXCITING
BUT WITHOUT ANY DETAILS OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS- IT CAN. TAKE A COUNTY
TO UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
THAT MORE DAMAGE THAN GOOD ALONG
THE WAY YES I HOPE THAT THESE
PROPOSALS MOVE FORWARD THIS YEAR
THAT WE HAVE A DIFFERENT-
APPROACH AND LAST YEAR WE HAVE A
LOT MORE DETAILS AND I JUST MUCH
MONEY BEING THROWN OUT THERE.
WITHOUT THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. I
WELL- TO THAT TO COME IN AND
THEN I A QUESTION YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PORTS. AND THE GOODS
MOVEMENT- AND THE BACKLOGGED AT
THE PORTS. THAT'S IN LARGE PART
DUE BECAUSE WE HAVE RECORDS
EVERY MONTH OF GOODS COMING INTO
THAT PART. AND GOOD TECHNIQUE TO
GET ON TRUCKS- TO GET OUT OF
THAT PORT AND EITHER RUN THROUGH
ONE SIDE OF MY DISTRICT TO THE
AT THE OTHER END OF MY DISTRICT
INTO. THEIR RAILYARD ARE INTO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AS WELL AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LANDS THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO PUT AS
WE LOOK AT OUR QUALITY- IT'S-
ARE THERE DETAILS OF HOW ARE
ALSO GOING TO ENSURE THAT AS WE
DO WITH THAT BACKLOG WE'RE NOT
OVER BURDENING. THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SUPPORT WITH OTHER MEASURES IN
THIS BUDGET- WHETHER THAT'S
THROUGH ADDITIONAL TRUCKS MOVING
A BUNCH OF EMPTY CONTAINERS INTO
MY BACKYARD. AROUND MY BACKYARD.
NOT IN AND OUT OF IT AND THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY SEEN A LOT OF THIS
AND TO CONTAINERSHIP ON THE MANY
BROWN FEELS. MY DISTRICT AND
THAT'S ALSO DELAYING SOME OF THE
WORK WE HAVE TO CLEAN UP SOME OF
THOSE BROWN FEELS. AND CONVERT
THEM AND SO- ARE THERE ANY
DETAILS ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
ENSURE THAT THAT SAME EQUITY
LENS IS BEING USED AS WE DEAL
WITH THE PORT CONGESTION. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT A LOT OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE RELATED TO
THE PORTS. ARE IN. REPLACEMENT
OF- BUT- VEHICLES THAT ARE.
CONCRETE YOU KNOW GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- AND WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO CLEAN UP IN TERMS OF.
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL. ZERO
EMISSION. EQUIPMENT AND OTHER
TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL
HELP TO. CREATE A CLEANER
ENVIRONMENT THE AIR AROUND- THE
PORTS THAT'S ONE THING- AND I
KNOW THAT FOR ALSO ATTEMPTING TO
FIND. PLACES AROUND THE STATE
THAT HAVE. THAT WE CAN CARRY
THOSE BIG CONTAINER TO THE ARMS-
CREATING CONGESTION IN AND
AROUND THE PORTS. BUT FOR A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL I'LL TURN TO
TREAT SICK HELP. FINANCE THE
OTHER THING IN ADDITION TO WHAT
ERROR- WOULD POINT TO THE DETAIL
REGARDING ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE. AT
THE GAMES THEY'RE HELPING
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES WITH
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU THAT
YOU ASIDE IF WE DO HAVE- DETAIL
FOR A NUMBER OF PARTS- PROPOSALS
IN OUR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
NOT SURE THAT GOES INTO THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR BUT HAPPY THAT YOU
DISCUSSION OF COURSE BUT THIS
PROPOSAL DURING THE SPRING. I
JUST WANT. ONE EMPHASIZE THAT IN
AND AROUND THE PORTS ARE MOSTLY
ALL DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ALONG THE SEVEN TEN FREEWAY- AND
SO. WHILE WE NEED TO TRANSITION
pIMMEDIATE AS REMOVING ALL THOSE
IN TWO CONTAINERS TO A SPOT
SOMEPLACE IN AND AROUND THE
PORT. IT'S IN THE SAME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING WITH
HEALTH. ISSUES WITH AND BECAUSE
pIT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT. WE
DON'T JUST TALK ABOUT THE POOR
BUT WE TALK ABOUT THE WHOLE GOOD
MOVEMENTS- IT TOGETHER IN THIS
DISCUSSION SO JUST LOOK FORWARD-TO THAT DISCUSSION. AS AS THE
YEAR MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOT GO TO MR GALLAGHER AND
THE MISTRUTH. YES SR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- JUST FEW
COMMENTS ON ITEMS IN THE BUDGET-
I'LL START WITH WILDFIRE- AS I
AGREE WITH MIKE WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE VICE CHAIR- WE
REALLY NEED TO SEE THOSE REPORTS
- SO THAT WE KNOW. EXACTLY HOW
MUCH ACRES ARE BEING TREATED
WITH THE MONEY ALLOCATED LAST
YEAR I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- FOR YOU KNOW
DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR. AND MAKE
SURE THAT- IS GETTING US TO THE
GOAL OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR- I'D ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE FIFTY MILLION ON
REFORESTATION THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT AS- AS
BEING PART OF REFOREST IN AREAS
THAT ARE RECENTLY BURNED. I JUST
WANT TO REALLY EMPHASIZE- YEAH
RIGHT NOW I'M IN IN THE NORTH
STATE WERE DEAL WITH ABOUT A
MILLION ACRE. BURN SCAR FROM THE
DIXIE FIRE AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THERE'S JUST LIKE NOTHING
OUT THERE. AND THEY JUST GO IN
THERE AND START PLANTING SOME
TREES IT'S- BURNED DEAD AND
DYING TREES THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE. MILLION ACRES YOU HAVE TO
GO ON THEIR FIRST TO THE FUELS
REDUCTION- SALVAGE- WOOD AND
TIMBER THAT YOU CAN. IN THESE
AREAS AND DO THE FUELS REDUCTION
AND THEN YOU CAN. YOU KNOW GOING
TO DO THAT. THE REFORESTATION
EFFORTS SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THAT WE DON'T LOSE FOCUS
ON THE NEED TO DO THAT- AND
AGAIN GETTING TOWARDS THAT FIVE
HUNDRED. THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR
GOAL- ON THE EDUCATION FRONT I
DO WANT TO SEE IS FOCUS. AND
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION LAST
YEAR ABOUT DOING SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR THOSE-
MIDSIZE RULE SCHOOLS THAT THAT
HAVE HAD SOME DISPARITIES IN
THEIR FUNDING- JUST BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THAT WE CALCULATE-
FUNDS- AND ALSO GOT SHORT
CHANGED. I WAS SOME OF THE- THE
CODE FUNDING LAST. LAST YEAR'S
I'D LIKE TO SEE IF WE COULD DO
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING HELP
SUPPORT THOSE SCHOOLS- OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED ON HOUSINGS. SIDE
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
PROGRAM GREAT PROGRAM- THERE'S
ACTUALLY WE GOT SOME FUNDING IN
CHICO FOR THAT PROGRAM TO- DO
SOME OF ROAD WIDENING IT WAS
THERE'S MUCH NEED THAT'S GOING
TO BRING ON THREE HUNDRED. NEW
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ONE
PROBLEM WE GOT A SEQUEL LAWSUIT
RIGHT AFTER WE GOT THE GRANT AND
THAT IS HOLDING UP. THIS PROJECT
SO WE'RE GONNA NEED THAT COMBINE
THAT WITH SOME SEEK REFORM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPRIET JEX THAT
WE NEED TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- DON'T GET HELD UP- AND
THEN LASTLY I JUST FOCUS ON ON
THE ON THE CLIMATE DISCUSSION. I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
THE CARBON CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY
AND REALLY MAKING INVESTMENTS.
THERE IT IT TO ME IT STRIKES THE
PERFECT BALANCE OF PROTECTING
JOBS IN THIS STATE. AND REACHING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AT THE GOT A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT- IF
WE ALL WORK TOGETHER AND I THINK
THERE- YOU KNOW OR- EVEN A YOU
KNOW ALL BALL HIGHLIGHT JUST
FROM. FROM MY STEP SOMETHING I
CARE A LOT ABOUT BIOMASS. WE CAN
CERTAINLY BUILD NEW BIOMASS
PLANTS WITH CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY- IT CREATES THE CAN
CREATE HYDROGEN. WE CAN DO THIS
AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS AND WE REALLY GOT
TO GET IT RIGHT SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN- GET SOME REAL STRONG
INVESTMENTS ON THAT FRONT AS
WELL. THANK YOU. I THINK YOU
WERE GOING TO THE MYSTERY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST FIRST
ONE STARTS IN COLLEGE AND I HAVE
A QUESTION ABOUT SPECIFIC
PROGRAM SO FIRST I WANTED TO SAY
I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT MOVE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE FOCUSED ON THE
AND- WELL N. O. L. A. N. RD TAX
CREDITS TO REVITALIZE OUR
ECONOMY. AND MAKE SURE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK WHILE ALSO TAKING
CARE OF OUR WORKERS AND ALSO IN
COMBINATION THE SMALL BUSINESS
GRANTS I THINK IS THE RIGHT STEP
A LOT OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY MY DISTRICT THAT ARE
IMMIGRANT OWNED AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR OWN ARE REALLY SUFFERING
TO THIS PANDEMIC. BUT TO PIVOT
TO MY QUESTION ALSO SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY MUCH- ALL RIGHT
NOW. IS THE- LOT OF STRUGGLING
SMALL LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN MARCH. WE
ARE ABOUT TO HAVE THOSE TENSE
PROTECTIONS EXPIRE. BUT I
REMEMBER LAST YEAR AND IN THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT I SHOULD TALK
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
OVER LAST YEAR. WE'RE TALKING TO
DESIGNING THE RENTAL RELIEF
PROGRAM WE GET UPDATES. FROM THE
AGENCIES BUT I TO MY KNOWLEDGE I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY UPDATES
ABOUT THAT. SO I'VE BEEN READING
EVEN MY LOCAL PAPER THAT. THERE
ARE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF UNMET
NEED AND RENTAL RELIEF PROGRAM.
SO FIRST I JUST WANT TO ASK. HIM
HOW MUCH MONEY. HAS BEEN
REQUESTED BY STRUGGLING
LANDLORDS IN THE STATE. AND HOW
MUCH. HOW MUCH OF THAT SO HOW
MUCH WHAT MONEY OF THAT HAS BEEN
PAID. AND HOW MUCH OF IT OF THE
REQUEST MONEY STILL SITTING ON
PAID. YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION MISTER LEE I HAVE SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION AND THEN I
WILL TURN IT TO CHRIS COOK FOR
SOME DETAILS BUT- AT THIS POINT
AS OF. JANUARY SEVENTEENTH-
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
OUT ACTUALLY FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN TO BE EXACT. COMPLETED
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
FOR STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE-
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
EIGHT BILLION HAS BEEN PAID TO
DATE. AND THAT'S PROVIDING
BELIEVE TO OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS- THAT'S
SORT OF THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION UP- ABOUT SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASKED. I
WILL TURN INTO CHRIS COOK TO SEE
IF YOU CAN FILL IN THE GAPS.
ACTUALLY I THINK. MISLI
ADDRESSED A LOT OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT I MISSED- WOULD
YOU MIND REPEATING THE QUESTION.
SURE SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
ANSWER THAT HAVE PROVED WE HAVE
ONE POINT SEVEN EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR. THAT'S
FORTY SIX THOUSAND COMPLETED
APPLICATIONS HOW MANY APPROVED
BUT PENDING APPLICATIONS ARE
STILL WAITING FOR MONEY AND HOW
MUCH MONEY WITH THE RESULT I
WENT HOW MUCH MONEY. WOULD THAT
AMOUNT TO. YES THANKS FOR
REPEATING THAT I HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON ON. WHAT THE
PENDING CLAIMS- APPLICATIONS
ARE. TRYING I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IN FRONT OF ME AT
THE FRONT FROM THE MEDIA STORIES
I'M SAYING THEY S. A. B. C.
STATE OFFICIAL ESTIMATE IT'S AN
WE NEED AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S MORE
THAN THE AMOUNT. EVEN GIVEN OUT
RIGHT NOW. SO I DO HOPE IT'S A
PRIORITY OF THE- ADMINISTRATION
TO SEEKING FEDERAL HELP AND TO
ALSO WORK AND JUMP TO. WORK AT A
COOPER LEAVE US TO HELP- GET
STRUGGLING LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
THE MONEY TO RESERVE. AS A LOT
OF JURISDICTIONS AT THE EVENT
AND MY- IN MY DISTRICT THAT HAVE
TIED THE EVICTION MORATORIUM TO
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND
THAT MEANS A LOT OF LANDLORDS
OUT THERE THAT I'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO APPLY FOR MONEY.
TO GET APPROVED AND YET WE'RE
STILL WAITING AND WAITING AND
WAITING FOR THE MONEY TO GET
THERE. AND MEANWHILE THE CRISIS
STILL IS PROLONGED AND I JUST
MEAN FOR MORE MONEY SO I DO HOPE
THAT. I AM I AM GOING THAT WILL
PLAY SEVEN EIGHT. DOLLARS OF
DISPERSED SOUNDS LIKE THE NEED
IS MUCH MUCH LARGER THAN THAT
OUT THERE. SO THANK YOU. YES AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO ADVOCATE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR- ADDITIONAL-
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
REALLOCATION DOLLARS INCLUDING-
ONCE FOR. THE SECOND ROUND
WHICH- COULD BE COMING OUT. AS
SOON AS- NEXT MONTH BUT THEN
ALSO IN THE COMING MONTHS
THEREAFTER. THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT GONNA MISTER LUCKY.
YEAH THANK YOU MINE IS MOSTLY- A
COMMENT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST OFF JUST TO SAY HOW
APPRECIATIVE I AM OF THE EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S BEEN
. YOUR MARK FOR ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IT'S BECOME A TRUE CRISIS
OUR CULTURE. AND IT DESERVES
ATTENTION VERY THANKFUL FOR
THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
FRUSTRATED OVER- AND I BUT I AM
THANKFUL FOR THE FIVE MILLION TO
DOJ. TO TAKE ON ANTI CRIME TASK
FORCES. HOWEVER THERE THERE'S A
VERY GLARING. PROBLEM IN THAT
THE ARE PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM
BACKLOG. THAT'S IT FOR THOSE WHO
MAY BE UNFAMILIAR WITH THAT
THAT'S- THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
COMMITTED VIOLENT CRIMES AND WHO
ARE NOT PERMITTED TO HAVE
WEAPONS WE KNOW THEY HAVE THEM.
AND WE HAVE NOT RECOVERED THEM-
I'D I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD
UNDERSTAND WITH OUR INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIME RATES THAT- THOSE
ARE VERY. LIKELY MORE LIKELY
HIGH RISK INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED
TO BE ON ARMED. THE LAST THING I
WILL SAY IS THAT- I WISH AND I
HOPE AND I WORK WITH IN THE SUB
COMMITTEE PROCESS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS A VERY VERY
CATASTROPHIC CIRCUMSTANCE IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS. THE ILLICIT
CANNABIS GROWS THAT ARE. ALL
OVER THE PLACE IN THE DESERT AND
OTHER CARTELS HAVE CLEARLY
INVESTED MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENTS IN THAT REGION AND
THE STATE IS NOT EVEN PAYING
ATTENTION. SO I HOPE TO BRING
ATTENTION TO THIS VERY SERIOUS
A- CANCER OF OUR CULTURE AND- I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU MR LACKEY
AND APPRECIATE YOU HIGHLIGHTED
THE APPS PROGRAM WHICH IS
DEFINITELY. IN NEED OF
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT. LOOKING
BACK AT THE COMMITTEE- SEEING
NO. FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
THINK I WOULD JUST. AND BEFORE I
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN JUST
REITERATE AGAIN- WHAT THE VICE
CHAIR DISCUSS WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER AND I THINK WHAT
WHAT A MANY OF THE SUBSURFACE.
TALKED ABOUT IS JUST THE LIST
OF. OVERSIGHT ISSUES THAT WE ARE
PLAN TO TACKLE OVER THE COMING
WEEKS WE KNOW WE HAVE FORTY
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING SCHEDULED
WE ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL GET
TO. OUR USUAL FULL SLATE OF SUB
COMMITTEE HEARINGS EVEN- EVEN
UNDER THESE COVERT PANDEMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT JUST TO GIVE
EVERYBODY A SENSE OF THE
OVERSIGHT ITEMS THAT WE WILL BE
TAKE A LOOK AT ONE IS. AROUND
PRISON OPERATIONS OBVIOUSLY THE
COVERT OUTBREAKS IN THOSE A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES AS WELL
AS THE- INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT OF
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL- OBVIOUSLY THE CONTINUED
EXPANSION AND FUNDING FOR.
PUBLIC HEALTH ACCESS AS WELL AS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
CAL AIM PROGRAM- CHILD WELFARE
AND FOSTER CARE PROGRAM
OVERSIGHT- THE CONTINUED
EXPANSION OF T. K. A SCHOOL
FUNDING AS WELL AS EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION- WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT. GOD THE SIGNIFICANT
OUR CLIMATE AND ENERGY PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE MADE LAST-YEAR BUT ALSO LOOKING AT THE
PROPOSALS FROM THIS YEAR. WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSIONS AROUND
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EFFORTS AS
WELL AS WATER IN DROUGHT RELIEF-
OBVIOUSLY- MISS CARILLO- AND SUB
FOR WILL BE LOOKING AT EDT IS
THAT RIGHT CONTINUES TO REMAIN A
HOT BUTTON ISSUE AS WELL AS-
HOUSING. AFFORDABLE HOUSING RENT
RELIEF FOR UTILITY RELIEF AND
HOMELESSNESS- WE WILL BE TAKING
A LOOK AS WE- CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT OUR BROADBAND
INVESTMENT LEASE SO SET ASIDE
MONEY FOR THAT PROPOSAL BUT DID
NOT. ACTUALLY END UP DEVELOPING
ON THE DETAILS OF THAT SO WE'LL
BE LOOKING FORWARD TO START
HIGHLIGHTS OF SOME OF THE ITEMS
THAT WILL BE TAKING A LOOK AT
EACH OF THE- SUB HEARING SO. NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE SOME PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE ROOM LET
THAT LET THEM GO AND THAT ALSO
WILL I TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
AGAIN JUST TO. REITERATE THE
PUBLIC PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO NINE
SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. THE FREE BEER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HAVE ONE THAT HAS
RISEN ONE MINUTE YES OKAY THANK
YOU A CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THREE QUICK ITEMS.
THE FIRST IS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
YOU I PROPOSAL WE DO SUPPORT IT.
THE THREE BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE TWO FISCAL YEARS- THE
CURRENT DEFICIT IS NINETEEN
POINT SEVEN IN THAT BURDEN FALLS
ON THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY BUT
DON'T FORGET. THAT THE STATE
PAYS AN INTEREST PAYMENT D. O.
F. ESTIMATES FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DUE TO THE FEDS.
IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR SECOND
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S. TAX
PROPOSALS PARTICULARLY THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION
CONFORMITY WHICH HAS TO BE AN
URGENT ITEM. SO THE TAXPAYERS
AREN'T SOCKED MARCH FIFTEENTH
AND APRIL FIFTEENTH. AS WELL AS
ELIMINATION OF THE THIRD YEAR OF
THE CAP ON BUSINESS TAX CREDITS
IN THE AND A WELL SUSPENSION.
AND CONCERNING THE PAID SICK
LEAVE WE HOPE IT IS PERSPECTIVE-
THAT IT. RELIES UPON PUBLIC
ENFORCEMENT THROUGH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND NOT PRIVATE
ACTION. AND DON'T FORGET THAT
THERE ARE NO FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
AVAILABLE IN THIS YEAR'S- EFFORT
OUGHT NOT PAID SUPPLEMENTAL SICK
LEAVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK OR- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF TO CLIENTS TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL INDEPENDENT VENUE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
INDEPENDENT LIVE EVENT VENUES
AND PROMOTERS ONE IS A STATE
ALSO SUPPORT FOR THE TAX
CONFORMITY FOR. RECIPIENTS OF
THE FEDERAL SHUTTER VENUE
OPERATORS GRANT- THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THAT INCLUSION ALSO WANT EXPRESS
HOPE FOR BUDGET LANGUAGE TO
ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLICATIONS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LIVE EVENT
VENUES PROGRAM WITH UNUSED FUNDS
SOME OF THE EXISTING GUIDELINES
HAVE PROVEN TO BE INADVERTENT
BARRIERS ARE DISQUALIFIER IS
FROM ANYWHERE THE APPLICANTS TO
APPLY. LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
I'LL BE HAVE A POUCH SHELTER
WHEN EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL OF ONE ABILITY TO BE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM TO PURCHASE AND INSTALL
TINY HOMES- PALETTE SHELTERS
WORK SETTING UP- SHELTER
VILLAGES THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH JURISDICTIONS
LARGE AND SMALL IT IS A RELIABLE
SOURCE OF FUNDING THAT MANY OF
THESE PROJECTS JURISDICTIONS
NEED AND- WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
TO DEVELOP THESE PROJECTS. GET
FOLKS OFF THE- THE STREET AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE I LOOK FORWARD
ALSO SEEN HOW THAT CONVERSATION
GOES HOPEFULLY THAT MAKES IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU WERE
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATE
EITHER. YEAH ABSOLUTELY. IF YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT THAT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIRST WE GO TO ONLINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
. HI THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
KING AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAKS IN MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MALLEY AND I AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
WORKING PEOPLE DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS HAVE ACTING WITH URGENCY
TO EXTEND PAID SICK LEAVE FOR
WORKERS STRICKEN BY COVERT. AND
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROVE THE EXTENSION OF PAID
SICK LEAVE IMMEDIATELY SO THAT
NO WORKER MUST MAKE THE CHOICE
BETWEEN GOING TO PARKS CHECK OUR
PAYMENT THE RENT AT THE END OF
THE MONTH. ADDITIONALLY WE
SUPPORT THE INVESTMENTS IN THE
HEALTHCARE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIZE THE JUST BELIEVE
FUNDING FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL FOR
ALL REMAINING ADULTS. WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR EXCITEMENT
FOR THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION TOWARDS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE OXFORD
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY.
CHAPTER PRICING. HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY. THE COST OF HEALTH
CARE CONTINUES TO RISE FOR
CONSUMERS AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS SESSION TO DO
SOMETHING TO CONTROL BOTH COPS.
EXIT OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS IS
BEING PROPOSED TO INVEST IN THE
RETENTION RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING OF WORKERS AND THE
CLIENT CARE ECONOMY AND
EDUCATION SECTORS WE ARE
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THESE
PROPOSALS THE BELIEVE STRONGLY
THAT WORKERS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS.
TO OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL TURN
INTO GOOD QUALITY UNION JOBS AND
ADDRESS SHORTAGES IN THE
WORKFORCE. LASTLY WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH A LOT OF LEGISLATURE
I'M PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LABOR
CENTERS. WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
RESEARCH AND DATA THAT WE ALL
YOU CAN MAKING GOOD POLICIES.
FOR THE GOOD OF ALL WORKERS IN
THE STATE. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE
THE RESTORATION OF THE 5% SALARY
STEPS FOR CSU SUPPORT STAFF.
LET'S NOT SEEN STEP INCREASES IN
THEIR SALARIES FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. I APPRECIATE THE
TIME AN OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT
THESE ITEMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT CALLER. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMORY THIS IS
HAVE NAME LOCK ON BEHALF TO SEE
IF HE A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS WE WANT
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE PAID
SICK LEAVE TO ECHO MY LABOR
COLLEAGUES WHO JUST WENT AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL THEIR WORK
IN THIS AT ENDEAVOR AND TO PASS
IT QUICKLY. WE ALSO WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR ITS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
INSTRUCTORS AND FINALLY WE WANT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING
PROGRAMS INCREASE BASED LENDING
FOR LCS AT WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
THE BEST WAY TO RAISE SALARIES.
WHICH WILL ATTRACT AND RETAIN
EDUCATORS. TO THIS PROFESSION.
THANK YOU. THANK ARE. ALL THE
COMMENTS REGARDING- THE
POLITICALLY WE WILL BE HAVING
ANOTHER HEARING. REGARDING THE
COVERT SICK LEAVE PACKAGE AS
WELL AS THE AND ALLOW ITEM- THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON PUTTING A
PRINT THIS IS THESE ARE JUST
COMMENTS ON THE- OVERALL BUDGET
PROPOSAL FROMTHE GOVERNOR IN
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING SO NEXT
CALL. WE ARE DEADLINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BRANDON TELLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN FUNDING
FOR THE AGRICULTURAL DIESEL
REPLACEMENTS AND UPGRADES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT- WE ALSO NOTE THAT
INCENTIVES FOR THE AB SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
REDUCED FROM TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION. WHICH IS A ONE THIRD
CAT ADDITIONALLY IMPLEMENTATION
IS FUNDED AT THE SAME LEVEL
DESPITE ADDITIONAL COMMUNITIES
BEING ADDED ALSO AIR DISTRICT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FUNDING IS AN
AREA WE URGE INVESTMENT SO WE
CAN BETTER RESPOND TO WILDFIRE
VENTS AND OTHER EMERGENCIES LAST
YEAR'S BUT ADOPTED BUDGET
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THE WOOD
SMOKE REDUCTION PROGRAM BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROPOSED
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDING
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO PROVIDE.
THAT AGAIN THIS YEAR LAST- WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO RE AUTHORIZE
THE AB INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
AND COST EFFECTIVE CARL MOYER
AND EIGHTY NINE TWENTY THREE
LOCAL INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO
AVOID DISRUPTION AND HELP US
MEET OUR CLEAN AIR. ACT
OBLIGATIONS THANK YOU. THANK THE
CALLER. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
I REALLY IT WOULD BE TO GET THE
APPLICANT VERY NINE THIRTY
THANKS FOR THE BUDGET DURING
TODAY. J. THE WORK ON AN
INSPIRATION AND LEGISLATURE TO
RESPECT BASICALLY FRAMEWORK
STRONGLY SUPPORT EARLY ACTION ON
THE ISSUE ON THE FOR THE
UPCOMING HEARING. I FOR THE
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS WE URGE MORE
ATTENTION FOR THE VACCINATION
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES DURING
DISASTER AND PROVIDING FINDING.
THE LEVEL CARE PROVIDERS TO
RECEIVE INCREASED COMPENSATION
FOR SERVICES THAT GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE TYPICAL CALL FOR
CARE. DURING THE TIME. FINALLY
ON BEHALF OF BBQ WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ENGLISH OF
THE CHANCE TO WORK IN THE
BUDGET. CREATE A COLLEGE FUND
CHAPTER TODAY YOU NEED MORE INFO
. FORTY DIRECTLY BE ADOPTED YEAH
. BUT THE PUBLIC. FOR GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELEVEN MR CHAIRMAN TO WERE IT
NOT WITH THE CENTER AND NOT
BROKE ON GIVING BE COVERED THAT
STATE THAT SCALE- WE WANT TO
GOODNESS FOR THE ROBUST CLIMATE
- HELP THIS YEAR AND THAT'S OKAY
. BUT WE DID KNOW THAT WITHIN
ENERGY. PORTION THERE IS NOT A
STRONG FOCUS ON HISTORY AND YOU
. BOB ESPECIALLY FOR D. R.
WORKING AND YOUR GOING. WE WERE
ENCOURAGE THE LAST BUSINESS
SHALL K. AT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WAS HI AND A HUNDRED
NOW OR- SO PROUD IMPLEMENTATION
WILL BE JUST. MORE AT BUDGETS
COMMITTEE HERE LOOK FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CAR.
MEXICO'S LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
CHANG IN NUMBER MY NAME DANNY
FOR HEALTH ALTERNATE PAYING THE
PROGRAM THE- I LIKE TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON THE CARE ALLOW YEAR IN
HER AND TEN FIVE HUNDRED AND
WANT. AND AN INCREASE IN THE
RATE FOR THE EIGHTEEN LEVEL
BECAUSE THERE IS NO THEY WERE
ONLY FUNDING A LOT MORE THAN
THAT WHAT THE A PATH TO WAS BUT
NOT PENNY BUILD A BIG THIS TO
PASS OF MOM ACCOUNTING OFFICE
WITH THAT. THAT THE COURT INCOME
FAMILIES WITH IN ROME YOULOT
COUPLED WITH THE THAT CLOSED BUT
CHAO CARE THAT. MANY OF THE
FLOCK WILL GO AND YOU ISSUE OF
THE NEW PLOT WITHOUT A PENNY
PROGRAM UP HIGHER A CAPACITY HOW
RESULT IN CASE LOADS.
524-021-0070 FIVE FAMILIES AND
NOT ON TOP TRYING TO AN RETAIN
STAFF THE RATE INCREASE TO THE
EIGHTEEN LEVEL NOT A FOR ROUGHLY
A OF THE TWO CARE IN THE STATE.
FOR FAMILY CHILD FOR IT ONLY FOR
THE NOT ON THAT DAHLE AN HOUR TO
TWELVE IN THAT RANGE REGARD LOTS
OF POLICE FORTY TWO OF THE
EXISTING 1-001-000-0500 NEW PLOT
ARE NOT EVEN SUPPOSED TO BE
RELEASED FOR DIRECT CONTRACTORS
CENTERS AND FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOME UNTIL APRIL. WITH EXISTING
LANGUAGE THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED
THAT REQUIRED ALL UNTIL WHAT'S
THE RETURN BY JULY ONE WE CAN
FORECAST THAT MOST OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE FORTY TWO
THOUSAND YEARS WHAT WILL BE
RETURNED AGAIN RETURNING. THIS
NOT INDICATIVE THAT THERE'S NO
NEED THERE'S GREAT MATE BUT YOU
CANNOT FIND IN YOU WALK WITHOUT
ALSO THE LEAD UP TO FOURTEEN
INCOME ELIGIBLE WITH INVOLVEMENT
IN ACCESS AND SUPPORTING THE
FUNDED WORKFORCE THAT PROVIDE
HOPING TO TAKE THE EDGE. CAPITA
MEDIA PER TO KEEP ALL OF THE I
FOR ALL OF THE NEW FLY IN THE-
ALLOWED. TO FIND. I WAS
SUGGESTING AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AT THE SECOND QUARTER THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK THAT LIES
AHEAD WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHTA
COUPLE OF THE KEY INVESTMENTS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE PROPOSED THREE
HUNDRED MILLION AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS AND LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE. ESPECIALLY THE
HIGHWAY SAFETY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM. INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
GRANTS. HE'S AKC LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING URBAN SUBURBAN AND
RURAL. WILL BENEFIT FROM THESE
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENTS. FINALLY
WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
ONGOING INVESTMENT IN REDUCING
BE. COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
WEIGHTLESS. I WHILE WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF INVESTMENT
ALTERNATIVES THE STATE
HOSPITALS. COUNTY THE POSE A
GROWTH CAPITALIZE T. REFERRALS
IN THE COUNTY KASHIRI
METHODOLOGY IF THE CAP IS
EXCEEDED THAT IS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE'RE EAGER
TO ENGAGE IN FURTHER DISCUSSION
WITH COUNTIES IMPACTED
STAKEHOLDERS TO LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THIS COLOR. MEXICO TO LINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON THE UP AND THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS AND
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE A HUNDRED MILLION TO
UPGRADE COUNTY JUVENILE
FACILITIES. AN APARTMENT ACROSS
THE STATE HOLD OUR
RESPONSIBILITY COMMITMENT TO
EACH AND EVERY YOUTH IN OUR CARE
WITH THE UTMOST PRIORITY AND IT
IS THIS COMMITMENT THAT GUIDES
OUR CONTINUED WORK TO
SUCCESSFULLY AND EQUITABLY
IMPLEMENT THE SHIFTED BJJ. THAT
THE STATE HAS GIVEN TO PROBATION
AND COUNTIES LOCAL FACILITY
RESOURCES AND UPGRADES ARE
NECESSARY COMPONENT TO BEST
SERVE THE NEEDS OF YOU. AND TO
REFLECT THE REHABILITATIVE
CENTER WORK BEING DONE EVERY DAY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CAR.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
ONLY A MEMBER AT ME YOU NEED TO.
HAVE YOU EIGHT NINE ONE ONE NINE
AND I'M CALLING ON THE BOARD-
THAT THAT MOMENT WILL PAID SICK
LEAVE I'M- HOW LITTLE THANK
PRESSURE VERSION RUNNING OUT OF
WILL BELIEVE. HAS MADE PEOPLE
ONE OF BACK TO WORK EVEN UNDER
BILL. AND DYING. IT'S PAST OPEN
BIGLY ME. TO AND I THOUGHT THAT
. HOW WORKERS AND THE COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. I ON PEOPLE CAN HEAR
ME BUT AGAIN WE ARE TO BE HAVING
US HEARING. ON COVERT SICKLY SO
IF YOU ARE HERE TO COMMENT ON
COVERT SICK LEAVE. IT CURRENT
COURAGE YOU TO WAIT FOR THE NEXT
HEARING. OTHERWISE YOU'LL BE
CALLING IN FOR THAT ONE AS WELL
THIS IS A HEARING ON THE
GENERAL- THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED WHICH IS A- VERY VERY
LARGE CHICKEN COMPANY REALLY
VARIETY OF ISSUES BUT IN TERMS
OF COVERT SICKLY FOR AWHILE OR
BEING
HANDLED IN A SEPARATE HEARING.
OPERATOR NEXT CALL. MEXICO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS. ON
BEHALF OF BETWEEN NINE THOUSAND
MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WERE IN STRONG POINT
OF MINE APICALLY PROPOSAL AND
LOOK FORARD TO HEARING THIS
ISSUE IN A COMMITTEE HEARING
THANK YOU. OKAY THE NEXT ORDER
FOR FURTHER COMMENTS ON
BASICALLY ALL THE CUTTING THEM
OFF. NEXT COURT. TO THE TO ALIGN
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHARGING AND MEMBERS
JOSE CORD WITH CONTACTED
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REMOVE
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND MEDIC
COPPER AND DOCUMENTED PEOPLE
AGES TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE IT A
REALITY. WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION AND LATER FIND
THE OFF OF THE POPULAR
AFFORDABILITY THAT YEAR AND
FINALLY WITH COVERED CALIFORNIA
DEDUCTIBLES AND COPAYS ON THE
RISE. WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT
MORE MUST BE DONE ON
AFFORDABILITY THEY WILL BE
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
PROPOSALS TO INCREASE. THE
FISHMAN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. OUR NEXT WILL TO
LINE ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI KATIE HARD ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND- EPA BELIEVES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A GREAT
START AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE-
FIJI ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOUR
COMMITMENT YOU REINSTATE. AMOUNT
PAID SICK LEAVE- SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP OUR SCHOOLS OPEN AND SAFE
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GARCIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION- CAL THE CCA
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR THREE BILLION DOLLARS OVER
TWO YEARS TO PAY INTO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND. YOU
DON'T THAT WOULD BE A GREAT HELP
FOR THE GROCERY INDUSTRY FROM
ANY PENDING UNEMPLOYMENT TAX
INCREASES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE THIRTY TWO BILLION BY HEAD
. HELLO MISTER SHARON MEMBERS
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP WHICH
IS GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
STATE BUDGET PROPOSAL. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SHOWN A
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
MARGINALIZED CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES YOU'RE A STRONG
RESPONSE TO THE ON GOING BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
ADVANCEMENT OF POLICIES AND
INVESTMENTS THAT ADDRESS
INEQUALITIES EXPERIENCED BY
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS ARE
ADOPTED AS PART OF THE FINAL
BUDGET. THAT CENTER ON
CALIFORNIA'S MARGINALIZED
CHILDREN. AND THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THE-
NEXT TO GO TO LINE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT THE STOCK OF
THE REGION FACES ENORMOUS
CHALLENGE IN REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION TOXIC PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
APPRECIATE THE EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR IT DISTRICTS. HOWEVER THE
PROGRAM WITH THE NEARLY
UNDERFUNDED WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCREASE THE FUNDING
TO COVER THE ACTUAL PROGRAM COST
THE NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES IN THE
PROGRAM HAS GROWN IN THEIR
TRACKS DISTRICTS ARE WORKING AT
DEFICIT IN EFFORT TO IMPLEMENT
IT. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING BEING. HOWEVER THE
BUDGET. THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET
HAS- REDUCE THE OVERALL NUMBER
FROM PREVIOUS YEARS AFTER THAT
YOU'LL- SIT. AT THE MEASURE THAT%
SOME OF THE PROJECT THE HELP OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SIGNIFICANT THE THING LOOK AT
THE FUNDING IT'S CRITICAL FOR ME
HELP IF FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. EXCELLING SORELY
NEEDED NEAR TERM EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. LASTLY WE SUPPORT
FUNDING HEAVY DUTY THERE OF
MOTION TECHNOLOGY THINK
ULTRAMAX. CLINIC IN THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER GIVEN OUR NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH NOW WE
SUPPORT FUNDING TO REPLACE
THOUSANDS OF HEAVY DUTY DIESEL
TRUCKS WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS. FOR LOWER COST PROVIDE
MORE IMMEDIATE. MISSION MISSION
PRODUCTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE CALLER. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATIE
WATER THREATS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE WERE HAPPY TO SEE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY ABOUT
THE NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL GET
SICK LEAVE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR TO
IMMEDIATELY ENACT TWO WEEKS I
THOUGHT THE SICK LEAVE FOR
OFFICE YOU CAN GO TO THE NEXT.
MOVES TO THE HOUSE SPEAKER THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE TO LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMUTING TO WORK WHEN
CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR
CRENELLATED WITH THE CALCULUS
CENTER ONE AND TWO PRIMARY
BUDGET PROVISIONS THAT ARE
BARELY KEEPING CHILD CARE
CENTERS- THAT CHILD CARE CENTERS
AND FACILITIES OPEN TO ENSURE
PARENTS CAN WORK IS REQUIRING
THAT PROVIDERS. PAID WITH
SUBSIDIES ARE PAID BASED ON A
FAMILY CERTIFIED NEED RATHER
THAN ATTENDING THE OTHER MAIN
PROVISION THAT IS KEEPING
PROVIDERS OPEN AND PARENTS ABLE
TO KEEP THEIR CHILD CARE IS
EXPANSION OF FAMILY THESE. BOTH
THESE PROVISIONS EXPIRE IN A FEW
MONTHS ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. YES ABSOLUTELY THAT
THE WAIVER FEES ARE. KERR LONG
AS POSSIBLE AND PROVIDING THEIR
BASED ON FAMILY CERTIFIED NEED
PATCH JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WELL TO ALIGN AT
ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI TIME IS A WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES WE
REPRESENTS COMMUNITY NONPROFIT
AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENT SERVICES. TO
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WE ARE
THANKFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR
COMMITMENT TO BEHAVE THE HEALTH
NEEDS DOLLAR WILL PROVE CRITICAL
IN TRACKING STATEWIDE ISSUES
SUCH AS YOU BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS SECONDLY DISORDER
TREATMENT IN HOME WITH BOTH. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE DETAILS OF
THE PROPOSAL HE CONTINUED TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF. HEALTH
PROVIDERS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT TO LINE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTEEN I
MEAN IT'S NOT CANNELLA CHILDREN
NOW CHILDREN NOW TAKES A WHOLE
CHILD APPROACH COVERING THE FULL
RANGE OF EACH OTHER ISSUES FROM
PRENATAL TO AGE TWENTY SIX WELL
WE APPLIED A NUMBER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS WE
APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
INVESTMENT THE HOBBIT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AND EDUCATION THERE'S A
GLARING LACK OF FUNDING FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
SPECIFICALLY PREPARED A THREE
YEAR OLD RESEARCH SHOWS
INVESTING EARLIER YIELD THE
HIGHEST RETURNS AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT WITH THIS
BUDGET WHAT'S NEEDED ARE MORE
DRAMATIC INVESTMENTS AND
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS ACROSS EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND ESPECIALLY GIVEN
OUR FATHERS HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
OR HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
WORKING PARENTS NEED A REAL
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS FUNDING THE
FULL CHIU COSTS OF OPERATING
CHILD CARE HIGHER PAY BENEFITS
AND ONGOING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT WHICH
EXPANDING CAPACITY WILL BE
CHALLENGING TO SUPPORT OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY NOW AND INVEST
IN OUR FUTURE PLEASE PUNCH HOW
CAN. CHILDREN NOW WILL CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
TO THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
FINAL STATE BUDGET. IS A
PRODIGY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. THE NEXT IN LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
YOU THREE LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER
ONE TO LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAURA GARCIA AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE LOCAL NATIONAL TO
REPRESENTING WATER WORKERS AND
I'M CALLING A STRONG SUPPORT OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE.
THANKS CALLER THANK YOU. MEXICO
EIGHTY NINE. FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI MY NAME IS RANDY
HEXAMETER CALIFORNIA TO
DISABILITY RIGHTS AS WE LOOK AT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE
SUPPORT PROPOSING TO ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR ON
GOING TO REDUCE MEDICARE
PREMIUMS WORKING ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES. WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO- TO HAVE
OF THE- OKAY THIS OUT NOW WHICH
IS A QUIRKY- GOING BACK AND
LOOKING AFTER HER NURSING HOME
INSPECTIONS YOU KNOW THAT THIS
IS A BIG ISSUE AND HAVING TO GO
QUALITY ASSURANCE WE WILL BE A
BIG HELP FOR THAT AND THE OTHER
THING WE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE FACT IS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE TO GET A CALLOUS ALSO
INCLUDED A MEDIC CAL INCREASE.
BECAUSE THE FACT IS THAT IT'S
VERY HARD FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO GET GOOD GENERAL
SERVICE AND EVEN IF THEY GO
THROUGH THE OF A PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY
DON'T HAVE- THE SAME QUALITY OF
SERVICE AND THEY DON'T GET THE
SAME QUALITY. OF OUR WORK AND SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE AS YOU GO
ALONG WITH THIS. EVENT INCLUDES
MEDI CAL SERVICES INCREASED IN A
CAL SERVICES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IN AGAIN- I
KNOW OF DOES ANYBODY ELSE. ON
THE PHONE LINE WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE IT'S SICK LEAVE
YOU'LL BE EXCITED TO KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A HEARING IN A COUPLE
WEEKS YOU CAN. COME BACK THEN.
THIS IS GENERAL COMMENT ON THE
GENERAL BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE
GOVERNOR. WE'LL GO TO NEXT
CALLER OPERATOR. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVE
MCCARTHY WOULD BE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. WANTED TO
VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT. THE PROPOSAL WOULD
EXPAND- INTO ADDITIONAL REGIONS
OF THE STATE THE SUCCESSFUL C.
H. P. TASK FORCE PROGRAM THAT
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS HAS
HELPED IDENTIFY. AND ROOT OUT
HUNDREDS OF THESE ORGANIZED
NETWORKS THAT ARE A PART OF SO
MUCH OF THE RETAIL JEFF PROBLEM
THAT WE FACE- THESE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE OFTEN MONTHS
LONG COMPLEX- TO INVESTIGATION
TO UNRAVEL THESE NETWORKS AND
SO- STATE LEVEL COORDINATION AND
RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIAL. PACKAGE
ALSO PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVELS MOST DEDICATED
PROSECUTORS. OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME- WHERE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE CURRENTLY
STRETCHED AND- THERE ARE FOUR
KEY CASES CURRENTLY BEING LEFT
UNADDRESSED NOT PROSECUTED SO
AGAIN THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
ARE MUCH NEEDED. IN ADDITION I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO VOICED HER
SUPPORT FOR THE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
TO PAY DOWN- SMALL PORTION OF.
THE U. I. FUND THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JIM CUNNINGHAM I'M A VOLUNTEER
FOR AIR. AND I APPRECIATE YOU
ARE PRETTY SWEET OUR BATHROOM
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS WE HAVEN'T CALIFORNIA.
APPLICATIONS FOR SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S CALL FOR EXCHANGING
OF A COVERT AT HIM SEVERAL PAGES
FOR A PROGRAM. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
NOT TAKING COMMON ON THE
PROPOSAL TODAY SO WE CAN GO TO
THE NEXT CALLER. MEXICO TO LINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING RICHARD TANG ANSWER
MEMBERS MINISTRY LOTS AND I'M
ADVOCATING FOR TAXPAYERS TO
CALIFORNIA ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AFTER LET'S USE HEARING
AND SOUND VERY CONCERNING TO ME
THERE'S NO MONEY FOR SCHOOLS ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS A P.
D. FRAUD NO ANSWER TO PAY OFF
THE DEBT OCCURRED. EXCEPT TO TAX
EMPLOYERS MARK TAX SMALL
BUSINESSES MORE TAX- LITTLE
EMPLOYEES- IN OUR DOUBLE DOUBLE
TAX EMPLOYEES. NO MONEY FOR ALL
RIGHT. CAC FORCES. YEAH CLEAR
PLAN FOR CARE. HELLO WHERE IS
ALL THE MONEY GONE THANK YOU ALL
HAVE A FROM THE FEDERAL. WE HAVE
A BUDGET OF. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS- FOR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO I LIKE YOU KNOW OF
ONE- AND THIS ALSO SOUNDS A
COMPLETE MESS TO ME ONLY TO STOP
STEP DOWN ON MY PEOPLE ISRAEL
SOLUTION STEP AND- WHAT IS A
SERVICE OF THE HARDWORKING
TAXPAYERS. I AM IN COMPLETE
OPPOSITION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO THE NEXT CALLER. SO IT'S
LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINES OPEN. LAVON TO LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS OSCAR SANDOVAL WITH THE
WHAT YOU KNOW COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA WE AT OKAY WE
ARE PROUD TO HEAR BUDGET THAT
ADVANCES AND PROMOTES NECRO A
NAME WE'VE GROWN VESTMENTS AND
HEALTH CARE FOR OUR HELP FOR ALL
FOOD FOR ALL COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WATCH FROM A PRODUCT
INVESTMENTS. OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR UP THE
STATE'S MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
AND THE OFFICE OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS WE ARE HOWEVER
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND
WHICH WOULD AS YOU ALL KNOW
DIRECTLY HELP FUND- COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DOING WORK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WASN'T INCLUDED. WE URGE THE
GOVERNOR TO KEEP HIS PROMISE OF
COMMITTING AT LEAST A HUNDRED
MILLION IN HEALTH EQUITY FUNDING
TO THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DOING THE WORK AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU GO
THE NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE I WAS GONNA TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT THAT'LL BE IN TWO
WEEKS MY NAME IS KEVIN HEALY AND
I'M ONE OF THOSE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN THE PRISONS THAT YOU
REFERENCED I AM A MEMBER JOB
STEWARD AND DIRECTOR OF SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND. WE REPRESENT
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THE
STATE'S EMPLOYEES PEOPLE WHO
KEPT THE STATE GOING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
PANDEMIC I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE THAT EUROPEI OR YOU
CENTRAL WORKER PREMIUM PAY BE
FUNDED PROMPTLY AND IN A ROBUST
WAY. ALSO TELEWORKING STATE
EMPLOYEES ARE LITERALLY
UNDERWRITING THE SURPLUS AND
SHOULD ALSO BE FUNDED SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO GROW THE ECONOMY
AND HELP RECOVER CALIFORNIA. I
PRAY THAT OUR HARD WORKING
MEMBERS STATE WORKERS ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND THAT THEY ARE
MADE WHOLE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE NEXT WILL BE
GOING TO NEXT CALLER. I'D LIKE
TO GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO LINE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. YES GO AHEAD. HI AM
I LYING ONE FIFTY EIGHT. YES
YOUR- GREAT WORK VERY CONFUSING
AND THE PHONE'S ALWAYS WORK- AND
YOU KNOW CERTAIN SHARES LIKE TO
CUT PEOPLE OFF MORE THAN OTHER
CHAIRS BY APPRECIATE THAT
TILTING IS NOT CUTTING PEOPLE
OFF. AND NOT WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA
DANCE FOR HER- QUESTIONS ABOUT
CHILD CARE- THURSTON SMITH ABOUT
HIS- EFFORTS T PROTECT CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND- VINCE FONG IN
GENERAL FOR I AM HOLDING THESE.
LAWMAKERS ACCOUNTABLE WITH THIS
BUDGET IS CONCERNED AND I ALSO
JUST WANT TO SAY SPECIFICALLY
THAT I'M CALLING TO REPRESENTS
THE SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP IN WASHINGTON DC. OVER
THE WEEKEND I WELL AS THE SEVEN
COOPER WHILE- CONVOY THAT IS
BRINGING FIVE THAT PEOPLE TO THE
CAPITAL OF CANADA IN OTTAWA. ON
BEHALF OF MEDICAL FREEDOM
BECAUSE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THIS VACCINE IT'S NOT
AFFECTING ITS MRNA TECHNOLOGY
I'M ACTUALLY QUITE SCANDALIZED
TO SEE YOU PEOPLE INSISTING ON
TESTING AND TRACING CHILDREN BUT
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE BECAUSE THIS
FASTER- GOVERNING BODY THE
SUPERMAJORITY LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY SHOWN ITSELF TO BE IN
BED WITH THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY AND THE PARENTS ARE
DONE THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO TELL
THEIR CHILDREN. THEY DON'T WANT
YOU TO TRACK THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEY DON'T WANT THESE VACCINES
AND WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF THAT
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
THE PHARMACY STAFF AS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BY THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. CHILDREN OUT OF THE-
CRAPPY WAY DAY. GOVERNMENT
SCHOOL I'M NOT A TO CALL THEM.
PUBLIC SCHOOL. BECAUSE DIDN'T
GARBAGE THE NOT WHAT. THEIR KIDS
OUT IF. RAFFLE. THE WAY IN THE-
AND NOW YOU WANT ALLOCATE. TO
PAY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TAX
BACK MEANS KIDS. BUT WHERE DOES
YOUR PHARMACY IS CRAP AND WE- HI
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU. WHAT KIND
OF COMPANY JOB WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE YOUR JOB THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO YOU OUT AND YOU'RE NOT
TO SIT THERE AND TALK AND WASN'T
HERE SO. TALK TO YOUR TO BE OF
WORK YEAH TO BE GOING TO IT N.
OUT THAT'S WHAT. IT IS THAT YOU
YOU'LL A SET FOR WHEN THE- COME
IN BUT YOU. BECAUSE STEP YOU
DROUGHT. AND YOU WERE GOING TO
GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU
- NEXT WITH WORKS THREE PLEASE
AHEAD. MY NAME KATHERINE AND I'M
ON THE OF S. I LOCAL ONE SOUTH I
LIVE IN TAMPA TO NINE. I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO SEE MY
REPRESENTS CHAIR TAKING SO AND
THE HEARING WILL WITH THE PUBLIC
- I'M A STATE WORKER I'M A
SENIOR ANALYST FOR THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND I'M
USED TO LISTENING TO CBC VOTING
MEETINGS WERE COMMISSIONERS.
REALLY LISTEN TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND SO I'M SHOCKED TO SEE THAT
THE HEARING ROOM IS EMPTY NOW-
I'M GOING TO REPEAT HAVEN'T
KEVIN HEALEY'S COMMENTS. AND
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER STATE
WORKERS AS TRULY ESSENTIAL- AND
GIVE US ESSENTIAL WORKER PREMIUM
PAY- LET KEVIN SAID THE BUDGET
SURPLUS WILL GAIN ON THE BACK OF
STATE WORKERS WHO KEEPS THE
STATE RUNNING. SO YOU KNOW AND
NEXT TIME WE ENTER CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS I REALLY REQUEST.
THAT YOU CONSIDER- GETTING BACK
PAY- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
HAVE A GREAT EVENING. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO THE NEXT CALLER.
NEXEO TO LIE ONE FIFTH NINE
PLEASE AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MIKE
CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY- FIRST WE
JUST WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE GOVERNOR. FOR THE
INCREDIBLE BUDGET THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO HAVE LAST YEAR- AND IT'S
FROM OUR ORGANIZATION'S
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE SEEN A MEDIA
RESULTS WITH REDUCTIONS IN
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA- AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE SOME OF THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
MADE. BUT HAVING SAID THAT I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT IT DOES FEEL
LIKE. TO PRACTICE BUDGET THAT
WAS PRESENTED WITH A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THE BALL
FORWARD TO DO MORE IN THE AREA
OF POVERTY REDUCTION. FOR
REDUCING POVERTY FOR CHILDREN I
THINK SOME OF THE AREAS THAT WE
WOULD LOOK AT WOULD BE- FUNDING
POWERS TO A LEVEL WHERE NO CHILD
WHATEVER LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY
AGAIN- WE WOULD SUPPORT THE
GOALS ESTABLISHED BY THE CHILD
CARE LOSS AND- FUND IN A MORE
ROBUST CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
BACKFILL WILL WALK WITH THE
FEDERAL CHILD TAX CREDIT. I WAS
HAVING. SUCH REMARKABLE RESULTS
IN OUR STATE- AND THEN ONE LAST
THING WE JUST. OUT IS. WE
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO BE CAREFUL TO.
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR- MAKING A
ROLL SYSTEMS PAYMENTS FOR THE
HERO PROGRAM THAT WAS FUNDED
LAST YEAR WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THAT PROGRAMS OVERSUBSCRIBED.
AND WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT WE-
GET THE RUN THESE ARREARS
ARNOLD- RENTS. PAID BOTH
LANDLORD AND THE TENANTS NEED
THAT TO HAPPEN SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP THAT IN
YOUR- A CONSIDERATION FOR THE
EARLY ACTION BUDGET. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TONIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CLIFF
SMITH THE BUSINESS MANAGER OF
THE ROOFERS AND WATER PER FOR
UNION LOCAL THIRTY SIX IN LOS
ANGELES. CALLING TO SPEAK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT WITH LINE
THAT NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD EVENING SURE A
SUBSCRIPTION- SOME CALLING ON
BEHALF OF IDW QUITE EXCITING I
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED UNION
ELECTRICIANS THAT ARE BUILDING
STRONGER COMMUNITIES WERE NOBLE
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE AND
LIGHTING UP SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. BECAUSE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNMENT THE WHOLE BEFORE
EXPANDING EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
TRANSITION TO A CLEANER ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE- THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD
CREATE GOOD UNION JOBS IN THE
BILL BY ELECTRICIANS SKILLED
RAINED AND CERTIFIED AS EASY
IGP TO CHECK ACCOUNT OR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE TRAINING
PROGRAM. AND ALSO THIS IS FAR
TOO IMPORTANT TO NOT MENTION
THAT PAID SICK LEAVE PROTECT
WORKERS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IT
NEEDS TO COME BACK IMMEDIATELY.
MY SON HAD CODE RIGHT NOW GET IS
THE PAID SICK LEAVE AND KEEP
WORKERS AND FAMILY SAFE THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL TO LINE AT ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXECUTOR RECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION JUST CALLING TODAY
TO VOICE MY INDUSTRY
APPRECIATION. WHEN YOU COMMIT
MINISTRATION PORT REDOUBLING ON
THEIR EFFORTS TO INVEST GENERAL
FUND AND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND REVENUES. IN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
RAIL SYSTEMS. THOSE INVESTMENTS
WHICH WILL BUILD ON THE
SIGNIFICANT NEW FUNDING ARE YOU
ALL OF THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
LAST YEAR FOR ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT. WHAT VEHICLE STATES
AMBITIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS BY
EXPANDING ACCESS TO EFFICIENT
MASS TRANSPORTATION AND FURTHER
TAILORING OU INDUSTRY'S
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. I DON'T KNOW WHY
HAVE MANY MORE DISCUSSIONS ON
THE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
PACKAGE IN THE COMING WEEKS WILL
BE BRIEF AND THEN JUST CLOSED
AND PAYING- THAT WE ALL AT THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH A
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IN THE COMING WEEKS
SOME OF THESE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC TRANSIT
RAIL AND EMERGING. OPPORTUNITIES
FORWARD THANK YOU. THE CORP.
ANEXIO TO LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MOLLY REPUBLIC PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES ARE
STRIPPED AWAY ACCESS TO ABORTION
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDING BACK TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. AND
ALL THEIR ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
THE NEW PROPOSED PLICY
PUBLISHED BY THE AGE GAP ON
FRIDAY AROUND THE USE OF THE
BUNDLE PAYMENT CODE FOR
MEDICATION ABORTION IN THIS
MOMENT WHEN ABORTION ACCESS IS
ON THE LINE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WOULD LIKE THE POLICY TO REFLECT
THE ABILITY PARK WHERE SHE
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
MEDICATION ABORTION SERVICES
THAT OUR PATIENTS. INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO OFFER THOSE THROUGH
TELEHEALTH WITHOUT TAKING A RATE
CUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS THAT
AS WELL AS THE WORK PROPOSED TO
THE CULPRIT FUTURE PROPORTION
COUNCIL OR PROUD TO STAND
ALONGSIDE A BILL ADVOCATES ARE
CHAMPIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO EXPAND
ACCESS. TO ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COURT. THE NEXT TO LINE AT
ONE PLEASE AHEAD. HI GREETING
ASSEMBLY. CRYPTO JOHN STATE FOR
CLEAR THAT SKINNER AND KNOWING
THOUSAND AND WHAT'S COMING
ADVOCATE FOR SMALL GRANT INTO.
FOR AND I A CHILD PROVIDER FOR
YOU GUYS YOU CAN FINDING IN A
FIFTY ACCESS COLORED
ENTREPRENEURS WHO ARE YOU THEY
ARE ASKED TO INVEST IN THE
COMMUNITY AND FAMILIES BUT YET
STRUGGLING OURSELVES. IF YOU
GUYS COULD ESTATE THAT'S WHAT
THE RENTAL HOUSING CLARITY THEN
FINDING TO SEE WHAT IS THE ISSUE
AND HOLD UP WAIT LANDLORDS BEING
PAID SO WE DON'T LOSE OUR
BUSINESSES AND GET HAVE TO FIND
A NEW PLACE TO RELOCATE AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CRISTINA GARCIA FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
DETAIL DURING CARDS TO WHERE THE
CHILD CARE OF MANY OF FINDING
IT'S. GOING IN THANK YOU
EVERYONE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. HOW
BROUGH THERE'S- NO OTHER COLORS. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THE TIME OKAY VERY GOOD- THAN
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENT IN THE
CHAMBERS IN KNOW THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WE WILL
ADJOURN THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET.